Greg,
out of the gate with that,
that's what I can.
Or Gas.
Yes.
That's donald trump's face.
You ever seen notice that donald trump's
face is running away from it?
He looks like he needs vaginal
rejuvenation surgery on his cheeks.
What happens to a person's face that it
just doesn't like their head anymore?
Just pulling away.
Yours is hanging in,
but his.
He's not that fat now.
You know what I mean?
Like Chris Christie's faces in better
shape than his.
Well being.
Fat helps because yeah,
pushes all the wrinkles out.
You get no wrinkles when you're fat,
but mine,
I'm Irish.
When you're Irish,
man,
you hit 40 and all of a sudden a fucky
turning on like a rotten apple core.
All the meat falls off the bones and
your your cheeks slink in and
they're close to a fix for that.
Really?
Yeah.
They're real close.
They're close to this guy.
I think his name is Peter was Dr.
Peter,
welling,
whatever the doctor's name that invented
Regena gene,
which is the blood spinning procedure
that coby Brian,
all these athletes going for,
he's invented some way to rejuvenate
your body's production of Collagen.
Going to shoot it into old ladies and
they going gonna look hot again.
I'd be all over that shit.
That is.
That's what makes you wrinkle.
That's it.
Makes your skin loses.
The last disability is Collagen and you
know,
if you look at like if you go to the
gym,
you go to the gym,
right?
Hell yeah.
You ever do you have like one of those
older ladies at the gym where you like,
I fucking smash that.
Some lady that's in her fifties,
but she's just doing squats every day.
Just hanging on like that.
You know that kitten in that.
A poster hanging in there,
baby hurting,
right?
She is not going softly into that night.
That's right now.
Then when you're,
when you're 23 and you're in shape,
you can get out of shape for a few
months and then jumped right back into
shaping and when you're.
When you're hang on kitty,
you take,
you take a week off,
you almost won't get back to where you
started again.
That's one of them.
Yeah.
This picture,
we're looking at a cute little kitten
hanging from a stick.
When you,
when you get to be like that age,
getting out of shape is really easy and
getting back into shape is fucking
nightmarish.
The first day back you're like,
Whoa,
yeah,
I am.
Oh,
I went to do pushups today.
And uh,
I used to be able to bang out 50
pushups.
No,
because I'm skinny as shit.
And I did gymnastics my whole my whole
life.
And so I just had good,
like muscle to weight ratio.
I fucking struggled to do 15.
I was shaking.
I was like,
what the fuck?
Just,
it really bummed me out.
I was like,
wow.
Because I said to,
to get back
to where I was would require a lot of
uncomfortable pain over a long period of
time.
Didn't you have like a real shoulder
injury or something?
Yeah,
I get surgery.
What was wrong with your shoulder to
cartilage can just wear out sometimes in
between your,
uh,
your,
there's three bones that come together
and your shoulder,
clavicle and the whatever the other two
are.
And uh,
so they basically go in and in two
different spots,
they go into your shoulder and they just
saw away the tips of the bones and then
scar tissue forms on each bone and it
acts as a new cartilage.
And you know what?
Fucking arm is good as no.
Unbelievable.
Yeah.
Wow.
Range.
Everything was great other than getting
hooked on Vicodin and everything about
it was very positive.
How long has it hooked on Viking?
Nine months.
Whoa.
It's unbelievable how many doctors will
prescribe you like it.
And if you ask a surgeon,
the surgeon,
the,
uh,
primary care physician,
the physical therapists,
and then I go to a psychopharmacologist
for my other little mood needs and I
don't know why.
This motherfucker.
I started writing scripts for pain.
Then he got friends.
Every friends got a medicine cabinet.
Joe Rogan.
Let me make an announcement right now.
If you're a friend of mine and you had
me over in 2013,
you may want to restock your,
uh,
your barbiturates.
Did you go to people's cabinet and just
scoop a few out?
It was bad.
I was bad.
I was the only three years ago.
Now it's probably five,
five,
six years.
Wow.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Can I even drank and you know,
25 years.
So was it a slow,
creepy thing where it's slowly crept in
on you?
How did you realize it had,
had you,
you don't realize until you stopped for
a few days and you go dark,
you go.
If you don't take it for a few days,
you get so sick,
like close to suicidal because what
happens is your,
your receptors for your uh,
um.
What do you mean for your dopamine?
Get clogged by barbiturates and you
can't do so if you stop taking them,
the,
the dopamine can't get into those
receptor holes.
Whoa.
Because they're filled.
Yes.
So,
so you can't feel happiness until
eventually those go away.
And that's why it's so hard to kick.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
So how did you kick it?
Just went dark white knuckled it like I
did drink.
And
did I remember when you did drink and
like that?
Well I met you right after you did that.
I met you when I think when I met you
you were still drinking and then like
right after I met you,
you quit.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's exactly right.
And I was amazed that,
you know,
I know a lot of people,
it's most people,
it's a struggle.
You have to go through therapy,
you have to go through a,
you have to go through all this stuff,
but you just knocked it off.
Well I did do therapy and also my dad
was an alcoholic so I,
I had gone to Al Anon meetings for
probably about year before I
quit.
And uh,
they knew the consequence.
I knew,
I knew the consequences.
I'll send you the steps.
Once you learn the steps,
it becomes like,
okay,
I know what I need to do.
I need to acknowledge that I have a
problem,
I need to work on whatever.
My higher power is.
Like I went through it without going to.
Because I went to some meetings and it
was just like too many guys,
like,
you know,
those,
uh,
those little bits,
those guys in Boston would do about,
um,
uh,
what was the,
what was the guy's name?
Teddy Burger on Eddie's like,
you see these guys at these meetings and
they act like they got it all figured
out.
The standing up there and I can proudly
say after 15 years I no longer crave
alcohol.
And he's like,
I'm in the back and I crack a soda.
They like,
oh fuck.
How many times have we talked about him
on the podcast?
But he's one of them,
not enough all time greats that people
just never found out.
Yeah.
The most raw talent Jerry Lewis kind of
talent where you just go like,
whoa.
Yeah,
this thing,
fascial,
Jerry Lewis,
Jerry Lewis was talented.
Dude.
You don't see,
you don't see it.
Oh,
I mean,
sure.
But they're not similar.
I just made God given talent,
but a weird comparison.
Why'd you go with Jerry Lewis?
I guess just the physicality,
you know,
they're almost like dancers.
The way they can move on stage.
Like teddy would just glide around and
is like hand movements and the way he'd
slide it was just kinda
what was telling in his timing was just
impeccable.
Right.
I remember when I was an open mic night
guy,
like,
uh,
just started,
teddy did a set and a,
he did a set,
like a,
you know,
just dropped in and did like 10 minutes.
And I remember thinking,
I fucking know nothing.
I don't understand anything.
Uh,
barely.
I shouldn't even be up there.
Yeah.
It shouldn't be allowed to do this.
But he got pills.
Got that guy.
I watched that.
I watched A.
I remember the Mattapoisett in.
Yeah.
Do you remember that kid?
Damn.
By Redondo used to have that Gig and he
booked me and teddy was like a classy
old hotel.
Well it was like a kind of bed and
breakfast or something like that.
Right.
So it had downstairs that had this
little showroom and it was real tight.
Seeding and small was an excellent gig.
Like when you got the Gig,
you were a great gig and it was in kind
of like a resort.
It sort of vacation the area,
so people were partying,
having a good time.
So it was a fun crowd.
And uh,
I remember teddy showed up and he was
just zonked,
zonked out on pills and it was just so
sad to watch.
It was like,
this guy was an all time great and he
was just so out of it.
And I remember being up at the,
uh,
the andover.
It was a club in Aa was addict already
gig.
It was at a club called CIC land and a
grill and grill 93,
something like that.
Ninety nine or [inaudible] 93.
Yeah.
And so,
uh,
teddy comes in on Friday night and he's
as shit the feature and I'm stretching
with material.
I don't have.
I'm doing your material at this point.
I got my hand above my head doing my
refeer girl impression and uh,
and he comes in late and then I see him
talks to the club owner.
He's like,
I was that guy.
You wouldn't believe it happen.
I'm coming up on 93 north and sky
sideswipes may knocks off my mirror this
after the show.
He says,
come out and look at my car,
and we got to the car and a side mirror
is hanging off,
and the guy was like,
all right,
so a Saturday and I comes up there,
I get to stretch sign again.
I got to do another half hour teddy
shows up and he goes and walks in and he
goes,
hey,
I got sideswiped and 93 north.
You got to see my side view mirror.
The guy's like,
are you kidding?
It's like,
no,
it's just fucking happened.
Oh Wow.
So he was so out of it.
I forgot.
He told the same log two nights in a
row.
That's his move.
Just kicked this fucking mirror pills,
man.
Hey,
you are.
You're swiping them from your friends
now.
Yeah,
it was ugly.
Brendan Schaub,
my friend had a nose job because nose
got broken in a UFC fight and he got
hooked on pain pills.
See the.
He was,
he's Bryan's partner on fire and the
kid.
What was he hooked on?
Oxy.
Oxy is where you can't turn back that.
That's the fucking hardcore.
He started out with Oxycodone,
sloman lighter.
Then you get into Vicodin and you know,
we had those guys on Chris and Mark Bell
from prescription thugs.
It's a new documentary that's out now on
itunes.
They're the same guys who did bigger,
stronger,
faster and trophy kids.
Great guys,
great documentary guys.
While this guy's doing the documentary,
he's doing a documentary around
prescription drugs and how many people
get prescribed them and how insane the
businesses and how over prescribed they
are.
While he's doing it.
He has to get hip replacement surgery
and he gets hooked now.
Shit,
he's doing the documentary.
He's hooked on pills and he's got to
kind of cover it up and these kind of
hot.
He's embarrassed because like he's
trying to put together this documentary
and he's hooked on pills and then
finally in the documentary,
once he becomes clean,
then he just comes clean in the
documentary and.
Oh Wow.
He was on pills.
Wow.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
He takes you out to his car and he shows
you his car,
like how we fucking collided in the shit
when he was all pilled up.
Yeah.
It shows all the dense and his
headlight's hanging off and it's dark.
Well,
Philip Seymour Hoffman got back on drugs
because he was doing a role that was
very.
I,
he on drugs in the role or was he drunk?
But whatever it was,
he'd been sober for like 20 years and
going into this place night after night
doing this play,
he started taking pills again and you
know,
any.
I just don't get why doctors prescribe
pills to somebody who's a known addict.
They don't give a fuck.
They don't give a shit that.
I think doctors get so used to people
being sick and people dying and it's,
you know,
it just becomes normal to them.
Just,
you know,
I had this woman,
Dr Rhonda Patrick in the other day.
She's a research scientist
and she was talking about a lot of the
experiments that they had to do with.
He had to kill mice and when she first
started doing these experiments,
should we get really sad and she'd cry
and this like.
It was like,
it was just really upsetting.
After a couple months she says gas and
these motherfuckers looking at
Auschwitz.
She didn't even care.
You just get totally used to it.
Yeah,
and I think for doctors,
you're a doctor for 10 years,
20 years,
30 years,
40 years,
all these patients are sick and dying
and all fucked up.
No one sees you.
If they're doing great,
everybody sees you because they got a
tumor or a broken leg and he just take
these pills and get the fuck outta here.
You're just a mouse here.
Have some cheese and some pills.
Chris Bell,
the guy who made that documentary just
sent me a text yesterday saying that
I'll say I'll forward it to you,
Jamie,
and you can put it up here,
but he was saying that there's a,
a new law that just got passed.
A doctors are urged,
okay,
this is what it is.
It's on US USA Today.
You could find it from yesterday.
I'm new guidelines for prescription,
uh,
to reduce abuse and overdoses.
So there are urgent doctors to try to do
something about this because there's,
they're finally starting to realize,
and I think a lot of it is just because
of all these documentaries and all these
internet blogs that are,
that are coming out and youtube videos
and all these,
uh,
new stories where people are really kind
of grasping the magnitude of this
problem.
I just don't understand why there's not
one database where you can have multiple
doctors writing prescriptions for the
same patient.
I mean,
if you go to cvs or rite aid,
there should be a listing of any time
you were specifically for the
recipients.
No,
fuck.
I mean it didn't stop me and I can
remember getting a fresh bottle,
you know,
30 pills in it and just holding your
hand like,
Oh fuck,
joy bottle.
It never took anything like that.
No,
never.
I took one time when I had my knee
operated on my first knee operation,
which was the Patella tendon graft,
which is particularly painful because
they take a piece of bone out of your
shin and a piece of bone out of your
kneecap attached to a strip of your
patella tendon.
Your patella tendon is a large tenant
that's in the front of your knee.
It's this one that goes from your knee
down to your Shin,
right?
Fat One,
and what they do is they take a slice
out of that and then they open you up
like a fish and then they use that slice
and that replaces your acl.
So that becomes a new acl because this
patella tendon graft is really big.
It's really don't need the whole thing,
the whole thing.
So they take a slice of that and it
creates a new acl and the pain was
pretty insane around the places where
they cut the bone out.
Yeah,
it was just like fire.
So they gave me something.
I don't remember,
it was Vicodin or percocet.
It was,
but I remember I took it once and I felt
so stupid,
like I was just like dirt or you think
it was Vicodin?
I was so dumb.
I mean it's just my own biology.
The way I reacted to it,
I was like,
I'd rather take the pain.
So I sold them to this dude at the pool
hall.
This guy named Jeff,
this Guy Jeff,
he always,
he would buy and sell pills.
He's a pill head.
He looked like a classic dirt bag from a
fucking Beavis and butthead cartoon.
He had like long hair that will go down
like this and one of those mustaches
that curled all the way down to like the
bottom of his like.
Whereas Chin.
Yeah,
did.
he was such a dirt bag.
This guy,
he had a pickup truck rusted out,
probably had a one of those El Camino's
we'll pick up and he would drink beer
out of the back of it with some friends
and he definitely.
He was a dirt bag.
Nice guy though.
But he was a,
you know,
just a classic classic guy.
I was like,
I can't fucking take these things.
He goes,
you got them at home,
bring them in.
I'll buy him off.
I'm like,
all right.
So I sold them.
I became a drug dealer.
She given me a bottle with your name on
it.
Oh yeah.
Fuck.
What the fuck was I back then?
Stand behind my.
Oh no buddy.
You know,
it wasn't like me today or anything with
my address or anything.
I was just struggling.
Standup comedian.
He liked to play pool selling drugs,
selling drugs to a dirt bag,
slang in the pool hall.
I was psyched to get that money to tell
ya know.
It's interesting like what?
Like 50 bucks is when you really need it
and is 50 bucks when you don't need it,
you know,
money loses.
It doesn't mean anything.
Like that's why I never understand
someone that works incredibly hard,
but they're already insanely wealthy and
they're doing something they don't enjoy
doing.
They're like constantly trying to
conquer and build a business and keep
going and going,
but they already have billions of
dollars in what they're doing is making
them miserable.
Not only that,
take it to a next level where you got a
guy like the Koch brothers.
Yes,
and they are not only working way harder
than they need to.
They've already covered the next 50
generations of kids did never have to
work and their family,
but they're killing the planet.
So if you're thinking about a legacy for
your great,
great grandkids,
they're going to live in a 140 degree
earth with no water surrounded by
fucking,
you know,
killers,
mad max.
Do you think that's what's going to
happen?
I think so,
yeah.
And it's all gonna fall apart.
I'm not stressed out about it.
I just feel like really,
you know,
it's gonna happen.
I'm gonna encourage my kids not to
reproduce.
I think that they're going to skate,
they're going to skate through.
There'll be a lot of terrorism and
there's going to be a lot of flooding
and some crazy storms.
We have third world countries are all
gonna be in an upheaval because you know
the environment is.
If it's gonna affect the poor first.
Of course.
I wonder how much it was blown out of
proportion and how much of it can be
mitigated by new discoveries and new
science and new technology.
Solar power.
Do you know?
Did you know?
I didn't know this until Eddie Bravo
came over here and I went down to the
God damn hole about
Rockefeller grandson.
Well,
yeah.
Did you know that Rockefeller made there
was a conspiracy to get people to use
oil instead of alcohol and that most
combustion engines work on alcohol and
they work just as good,
if not better on alcohol than they do on
gasoline and alcohol.
Obviously you don't need fossil fuels,
you don't need or whatever you want to
call it.
Vegetable.
Yeah.
Porn,
you know,
they run just as good on that.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
I mean he,
well,
between him doing that and then um,
you know,
for it,
didn't Ford buy up all the train the
train tracks in Los Angeles to create a,
a car society instead of a train
society?
Yeah.
There's some sort of conspiracy or were
they the auto?
I don't think it's conspiracy.
I think it definitely happened.
I don't mean that it's a conspiracy that
doesn't exist.
I mean,
they conspired that they could conspire
to do something like that.
I don't know too much about that though.
Is a film about it.
Uh,
they,
the killing,
the killing her killing of the car or
something.
Yeah.
Well that's different.
That's a late model.
That's who killed the electric car.
That was one of the electric car first.
See they had electric cars a long
fucking time ago.
We have the museum of cars and they've
been.
The first cars were electric.
Yeah.
How about,
you know,
these to Henry Ford and fenders that are
made out of hemp.
That was something we covered with shit.
Yeah.
You can hit them with a hammer.
Last videos of him like whacking these
fenders with a hammer because hemp is
hemp fibers.
Insanely powerful,
unbelievably strong and really
lightweight.
Like more powerful than fiberglass.
Stronger than.
I mean,
it's amazing,
amazing stuff.
And so he's hitting it with a fucking
hammer.
The Hammer is bouncing off this tender
that he had a shit bought back then,
man.
They were all jockeying for control of
this emerging industry and they didn't
see anything bad about just trying to
control the market.
Like,
fuck,
fuck these trains.
Yeah,
fuck your tracks.
Yeah.
I want everybody to have cars.
Like they didn't think one day I was
going to heat up the planet and polar
bears going to drown,
you know?
Yeah,
of course.
I mean,
if they could've seen that poster of
fucking,
you know,
polar bear stuck on a,
on a little,
uh,
what do you call this?
Ice Float.
Ice Ice floats.
Did you see the video that got recently
of a polar bear chasing down a female
and her cub and eating the curb in front
of her?
Yeah.
Holy Cow.
These explorers were there.
It was either explorers or might've been
a cruise,
but they watched it and they were
screaming.
No,
no.
And he just chases down the female and
she's running full clip,
but she's got the curb with her in the
cub camp.
Run that fast and following.
He grabs a cub and he eats it right in
front of her.
He think it was his child.
It doesn't matter.
They don't give a fuck.
All bears are cannibals.
Yeah.
You know when there's a real problem
with movies like Zootopia,
which I took my kids to see the other
day was really adorable.
Very cute.
Moving.
Not a problem with the movie would have
problem with what comes out of that
movie and these fucking.
What would you do for a Klondike bar ads
and these,
these things that anthropomorphize
animals.
Here it is right now.
If you want to watch it.
See that's the mother and the cubs
running full clip and there's the big
daddy can't run up behind.
It has taken off.
Right?
So we're just going to watch it on the
screen.
If we put it on you.
Can you go full screen with it though?
It's not going.
Oh,
okay.
That's,
that's the mom trying to head off
trying,
but he's like kid out here,
bitch.
She can't do anything.
He's like twice her size.
The honest stay tune.
There it is.
Boom.
That's what they do.
It's awful.
They eat them.
I mean,
when bears come out of hibernation,
one of the first things they do is head
for the cubs.
For Haley,
the male bears immediately go and kill
the cubs.
They eat them.
That mom is trying to put up a fight and
a little bit,
but she's just so much smaller.
She's scared and she knows the baby's
already dead.
There's nothing she could do,
so she turns and then just runs.
She realizes at a certain point in time,
this motherfucker might eat her too,
which does happen by the way.
Really?
Yeah.
They cannibalize each other.
They kill each other and cannibalize
each other.
Oftentimes when you hunt bears,
if you kill one bear and you leave it
like to go back and get a truck to pull
it out of the woods.
When you do that,
you come back.
Other bears,
we eating it.
Bears were all cannibals,
but my point was that like people have
this idea of what these wild animals are
that you know,
they live in harmony in nature.
It's chaos.
It's chaos and conflict and murder all
day long and cannibalism especially
bears a 100 percent cannibals.
All of them,
not only with,
when we were in Alberta,
my friend who runs a hunting camp up
there watched a male bear killer cub in
front of the female.
The female tried to fight them off.
The male bear killed a cub.
She chased him off eventually and then
she went and finished it.
Oh no,
she ate her own cup.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's harsh man.
I've got mad at my kids,
but like,
I pull up a little short of that.
Why don't think the male was the,
uh,
the father.
He might've been,
but who knows?
He might not even know.
She probably knew either.
I thought some bears were just ate
berries and shadow.
No.
All bears eat meat.
Yeah.
We'll all North American bears,
man.
They don't mean they don't eat meat
exclusively,
but they're omnivores except polar
bears.
Polar bears and 100 percent Predator
that the only bear that doesn't need
anything but meat.
They just,
they don't have anything up there.
There's no vegetables.
So everything they eat is just meet the
seals and anything that fucks up.
Yeah.
When you look at the territory is that
certain animals need,
like they were doing a thing about,
um,
about uh,
mountain lions in Los Angeles,
and if one there was a,
each mountain lion needs like 20 square
miles of territory just for him.
And if you get within that,
it's a fight to the death.
That's,
those are the stakes.
And so there's one mountain lion was
living up in the Santa Monica mountains
like above the Palisades Malibu.
And uh,
he somehow,
because they tagged them,
he somehow ended up over in griffith
park across the four.
Oh,
five.
Did you see what he did?
He killed a Koala bear.
Oh No.
He climbed a fence for the 12 foot tall
fence covered with barb wire,
got over the fence and killed a qual
bird.
Good for him.
You know where there's a will,
there's a way.
Will they found these mountain lions and
San Francisco,
you know,
because California doesn't have hunting
laws for mountain lions.
I mean,
they have laws against it.
You cannot hunt mountain lions,
right?
Wildlife Biologists are seriously
against because when you can't control
Predator populations,
they just breed and breed and breed
until it becomes too many of them.
Like you there.
They don't have any predators other than
a man.
So you know,
people can say,
well,
let nature balance and tickets will.
That means they move into neighborhood,
meet your friends were part of the
balance.
We're part of the balance and we think
we're not because we have the internet
and the fucking cell phone,
but the reality is they don't give a
shit about that.
So anyway,
these mountain lions,
they've been killing because they,
they.
What they have to do is when they invade
neighborhoods,
start killing dogs and threatening
people,
they have to kill them.
Well,
they killed over 100 of them the last
year and yeah.
Yeah,
they are.
They have to shoot them.
They just do it privately.
They don't talk about it.
It doesn't make the news,
but when they shot them,
they found out that their primary diet
is pets.
Yeah,
of course.
Cats,
dogs.
That's the primary diet like they were.
It was only like a small percentage of
deer in their belly and their bellies.
Did you ever see any cats around your
house?
I've never seen a cat around my house,
but I saw a cat that killed my dog in
Colorado and I saw another mountain lion
in Santa Barbara on the.
On a fucking residential road.
Yeah.
Big.
It wasn't that big.
It was like a small dog,
like 50,
60 pounds,
something like that.
But it was big enough to freak me the
fuck out here.
But people know in the valley you don't
leave your dog out in your yard.
You just don't know.
You can't.
It'll be fucking gone.
Well,
coyote is mostly.
Yeah.
But uh,
the,
the mountain lion that I saw in Santa
Monica or Santa Barbara rather looked
like a coyote.
Was that size wasn't that big?
I thought it was a coyote and then I saw
the tail.
Oh Shit,
that's a cat.
It's seen a cat is so much creepier than
seeing a coyote.
Yeah,
because you know that they like a
coyote.
I'm pretty sure I could fuck up a
You know,
if a coyote jumped on me,
I know I just grabbed him by his tail
and smash his fucking head off the
ground.
I had to figure out a way to.
When I get it,
I think it's because of a bugs bunny.
And you know,
the Wiley Coyote,
he was such a doof.
He's just can't take the breed series.
Lena.
Well,
they're scary.
I mean if a coyote wanted to kill you,
it,
it'd be a real rat.
Wanted to kill you.
It'd be a real fucking problem.
Right.
But I'm pretty sure if you could snap
and get into full rage psychopath mode,
you could probably kill a coyote.
Yeah.
But not a,
I don't think a mountain line.
You'd be fucked.
Well,
50 pounds and they sprang so fucking
fast.
So fast.
Yeah.
They're so fast and they're so powerful.
And if you look at their bodies in
comparison to like,
they're like one of the most powerful
cats,
pound for pound.
They have enormous wrists and forearms
and their shoulders.
They ripped.
Oh,
I try to get shelled is like that at the
gym.
I say Nick trainer,
I Want Mountain Lion Sheldon and they,
and so they have a machine,
you know,
and it's a shoulder machine,
shoulder machine.
That's the mountain lion.
When you put it in,
in this little pause and you growl and
you put on,
you know,
what just happened?
There were people dressed as animals at
um,
I just did the Addison Improv Club,
great club and there was a convention
going on at my hotel.
There were hundreds of furries and they
were fantastic.
They had like,
you know,
one is a zebra a lot,
a lot of like Unicorns and fucking
rabbits.
All mascots,
right?
Yeah.
They look,
it looked like a bunch of college
mascots,
but then some of them then you saw the
dark side creep in,
like some of them had little studied
collars on because apparently at night
shit gets a little weird with some of
them,
you know,
there's holes in the costume and there's
some furry sex going on.
A lot of furries.
So yeah.
Yeah.
But they were great.
I took pictures with like 100 of them.
I just get mad.
His thing is they're really into hugging
like the rule is,
if you just ask any,
any of them will hug you and I would go
downstairs and get a cup of coffee.
I'd hug like three.
Fuck,
that's hilarious.
Can have a hug.
Sure.
They just wrapped their arms around you
and pat.
You had their helmets on how they keep
them on?
Yeah,
they don't think around when they're
drinking the coffee and they keep it on
a daily drink.
Anything while you were like,
Oh yeah,
I did,
but I was talking to the bartender down.
I was having lunch downstairs.
I was like,
these guys drank a lot.
He's like,
I've sold one beer in the last day to
these just uber nerds.
Whoa.
Uber nerds.
They all have like the ones I saw at a
costume had like just those Pale puffy
faces that look like they're just.
The only light they've gotten is off a
computer screen of the last 10 years and
they really like asperger z,
you know,
we'd be on the elevator and they were
like a call out your floors and one guy
goes for other guy goes eight.
Yeah,
there we go.
It was so bizarre.
He goes,
uh,
84.
That's four.
It's half vate.
We are all looking at a griggs instagram
right now.
Did you talk to them?
Oh yeah.
Did you ask him what the,
what's up?
Yeah,
they said,
you know,
we're,
we're in my town.
I get made fun of because there's only
two of us to do this and then I come
here and I just feel like so free.
And so like,
you know,
among friends and the,
there's a bunch of conventions that they
go to like comicon type places and they
get to know each and you know,
it's like a whole community for them.
Yeah.
You know what I mean man.
I mean,
yeah,
it's retarded but no one's hurting them
or didn't.
No one's getting hurt.
I'm jealous of anybody that finds like
you've always had things you're
passionate about,
you know,
whether it's taekwondo or you know,
mixed martial arts or whatever,
and it's like to find something in your
life,
no matter what it is that gives you a
community and gives you something that
you're going to,
you kind of grow in over time.
It's great.
It doesn't matter what it is.
Jealous of that.
Yeah.
I never had that.
Never had that.
What will you have interest though?
I think family became the only thing I
will stand up obviously,
but family's the only thing I ever got
really into like longterm committed.
Don't get sick of
when you're old,
you'll be happy that you made that
choice because there's a lot of people
that made the different choice and got
really obsessed with something else that
lead them away from their family when
they get older and they realized it was
just bowling,
right?
Like why did I have to go bowl all over
the world and miss my kids growing up
because I got really into.
Yeah,
they a dude who was a big show runner
here in La and I was friends with him
and he got really into horses.
He bought horses and they were up in
Pasadena and he would go up there on the
weekends.
He'd work all week and he'd go up on the
He had a daughter and a one night he was
in the middle of dinner and he went
upstairs to his room and he put a
plastic bag over sat and he killed
himself.
Are they related?
The horses and the kill himself?
Well,
I think he was.
He was away from his family.
He was like it with this free time.
That's,
that's how he was spending it away all
the time and that's,
that's the only thing I could think of
that would cause it is like you ever sit
down with your family and this is the
greatest guy.
I mean,
I love this guy,
but it just,
it made me think like the saddest time.
Sometimes when you're with your family
and for whatever reason,
you're not feeling connected.
You're just feeling like they're talking
and you're pretending to listen,
but you're just in your head thinking,
why don't I feel close right now and you
know,
and there's,
most times you don't feel like that,
but once in a while you do and that,
those were like the saddest moments in
my life because it's all right there in
front of me and I can't touch it.
Ooh,
that's deep.
Yeah.
Jesus.
I mean obviously the guy's dead,
so there's no way we could ever really
know what his motive was or what the,
what the real big factor was that pushed
them over the edge now.
But I think sometimes people just aren't
fucking happy and I think it can.
You can narrow it down to a couple
different things or it can be.
It can be a group of experiences from
their life that they've never gotten
over.
It could be breakups,
you know,
I know people that have been dumped like
in high school or college and just
really never recovered.
They,
you know,
they had a love and then the person just
left them for someone else or something
like that.
And then they never bounced back,
they fucking nose dive and went right
into the rocks and just never came out
and never had another relationship.
It's fucking,
it's normal.
I mean,
it happens.
It wasn't about that,
like you said,
it wasn't about that relationship.
It was about what came before at
something.
Set the stage for them to be that
fragile.
That's the best way to say something.
Set the stage.
Like once I loved and it was a gas,
soon turned out,
had a heart of glass.
She was the first rapper she was,
or one of them,
unless she was,
she was hanging out with um,
uh,
the sugarhill gang and all those guys.
Yeah.
She hung out with the earliest rappers
and was like at CBGBS.
And then she'd go uptown.
Wow.
And she wrapped it out.
The sugarhill gang happened.
Like it was popular when I was in,
I think I was in seventh or eighth
grade,
I think I was in seventh grade.
I'm not sure one of those.
But when it happened,
I remember we were in the cafeteria and
somehow or another someone had a boombox
or something like that.
And they were playing it in my junior
high school when I was living in Jamaica
Plain.
I went to a junior high school,
was super sketchy,
like we had a,
we'd lived in a very bad neighborhood
and the Jamaica plain is kind of become
gentrified now a little bit,
but when I lived there like in 1979,
1980,
I guess when I lived there it was shit.
Yeah,
it was,
it was not good.
And there was kids in our class when I
was,
I guess I,
like I said I was 13 and there was a kid
in my class that was 17.
And uh,
you're not cheating off him during a
quiz.
Yeah,
it was weird.
Like he was there for the first couple
of days and then he left and then he
quit again.
You just never,
wow.
Never stuck it out with school.
And he was there for a little while and
he bailed.
And I was like.
And I remember the feeling of sadness
and I remember a girl in my class was
kind of a Ho.
She was also a little bit older.
She was a super 16 and she's a 13 year
old class,
right,
and she asked the teacher.
She goes,
if you'll make out with someone and you
breathe out and they breathe it in and
they breathe in,
you breathe it in.
Do you need any more?
Get fucking question.
It's not a bad question.
I remember.
I remember thinking,
man,
this bitch get fucked a lot.
She's like,
I'm tired of regular an f only from
people who are fucking man.
If your uncle exhales and you.
I mean,
you know,
hypothetically,
not my uncle.
Hypothetically,
if you in the basement and your uncle is
whispering into your mouth,
what a
crazy question.
Like if you could just breathe each of
those air back and forth and the science
teacher who is.
She asked a question to how to explain
that you breathe out carbon dioxide.
Then he was the first guy that really
kind of blew my mind.
I had one of those science teachers
like,
or any teacher,
like when you're really young that
actually make an impression.
I really wish I could remember this
guy's name,
but he was a Vietnam vet and um,
he,
uh,
he was,
a very interesting guy because he was
very calm,
but people didn't fuck with them.
He was,
he had this weird error,
but he had a beard,
which I always thought was weird,
is back then people didn't have beards,
hipster beard.
And uh,
I remember he said,
if you really want to understand how
strange the world is,
just go outside and look up and
understand that there's no end to that,
that it goes on forever and just,
you want to hurt your brain,
go outside and look up at the sky and
realize that space is infinite,
which means there's no end to it.
I don't remember the whole class,
you know,
2:16
year olds and the rest of us were like,
which is sitting there like,
what the fuck?
There's no end.
Like how come nobody ever explained that
to me?
I never even thought about it before.
I always knew that the universe is big.
I always new space was big.
But when he said that like,
no,
end,
like you start thinking,
okay,
and then further and further and then
for and there's no,
there's no wall,
there's no end.
Yeah.
So they can't be an answer because it
didn't come back.
Whatever question you sent out there,
can't come back because it's still going
out there.
It's like when I think about whether or
not,
whether or not there's a god that's,
to me,
I just think of the word infinity and I
just think all right,
if we can,
if science can ever grapple with that,
then I,
then I'll believe that there's no god.
You believe it was gone?
Yeah.
Do you?
What do you believe?
Like there's an old dude and a cloud or
no,
nothing like that.
I mean,
and I don't,
I can't articulate it that well because
I've never set out to make anybody agree
with me.
It's just my own personal part of it is
I think I was raised very Irish Catholic
and you know,
you uh,
you learn the 10 commandments.
Thou shalt have no other gods before me.
And you know,
you think about this force in the
universe that has all the answers and I
don't know that like I ever fully let go
of that,
but it morphed into Mike,
uh,
kind of a,
like a taoist.
There's an energy that flows,
like with nature and that all energy is
part of it.
And that your goal to achieve
enlightenment is to just become part of
that energy.
To let go and become part of it.
Like that to me is God,
is that there,
there is something that has created the
initial physical laws of the universe
and that those whatever happens within
that happens,
but that there was something that
engineered the,
the way that there are physiological
reactions within an atom,
the same way there are in a universe and
a mat.
I would imagine galaxies within the
universe all I'll behave the same way.
The Proton and electron work in a,
in an atom.
Well,
I think it's fractal.
I think that's one of the things that
they're starting to realize.
No one will look into subatomic and they
try to understand
like what?
What's the relationship between atoms in
the universe itself and I think as you
go deeper and deeper and deeper,
it starts to resemble the universe more
and more.
The universe is mostly empty space,
right?
Black matter which way,
they don't necessarily totally
understand.
Yeah.
Black binder is this weird thing that
they're trying to figure out to try to.
From the way it's been explained to me
by physicists because I'm an idiot and I
asked them.
I'm like,
okay,
try to explain this to me.
They don't know why these galaxies
behave the way they do.
They don't know why.
In one of the ways they have formulated
to try to make it make sense.
Yeah.
Is this concept of dark matter?
He and they say with Einstein theory of
relativity that,
that it is the black matter that has an
effect on the way light bands and then
we gravity acts upon things.
Physicists or listen to this right now.
What are these fucking monkeys talking
about?
We're not even.
We should get high and try to work this
out.
Oh,
like God.
Yeah.
It's really,
it really is intense because,
uh,
you know,
when I'm,
when I am feeling down,
I do start thinking about the big
question is just to shrink everything
the fuck down.
Well,
I don't know if the word God is serving
us.
You're right,
you're right.
That's a problem.
Yeah.
I think it's a loaded,
got a loaded word,
you know,
it's like a,
it's got too much weight behind it.
Yeah.
And also it's got so many meanings that
connect to religious fundamentalism,
ideologies that human beings have
obviously created,
you know,
women wearing burkas and all kinds of
wacky shit that's connected to these
concepts of religious ideology.
When you say the word God,
you immediately sort of,
you have a bridge to these
fundamentalist ideas.
Yeah.
And they're not that good.
I think it's almost like,
again,
going back to my Catholicism,
I guess it just became a replacement for
that,
that concept,
but you're right.
I think that is a,
there's a lot of stigma attached to it
and um,
you know,
trying to,
trying to get somebody to agree with
your God is the thing that's always
fascinated me.
Like why?
Why do you need a bunch of people to
convert and kneel next to you and all
have the same beliefs?
Why can't you just have your
understanding and be peaceful with it?
That's how you know that veganism is a
religion.
Yeah.
Because they're all trying to get you to
do it too.
They're all trying to get,
we're going to save the world.
We want to.
Polar bears are eating their kids saving
shit.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean the idea of stopping torture and
stopping,
you know,
a factory,
farming,
these are all good things.
The little less harm we can do is all a
good thing,
but there's something about that need to
convert people.
There's something about that patronizing
attitude they have.
There's something about this
overwhelming desire to incorporate other
people
into their group that completely smacks
of religion.
Well you
do that.
A Bikram Yoga,
right?
Yeah.
Cause I did a couple of classes and then
I found out it was a call harborside.
They started trying to indoctrinate me
into these long term contracts.
I was like,
can I just come and pay you 22,
500 and take the fucking class?
Do I have to agree with you spiritually?
Also while they say crazy shit to like
this,
this supports your inverse colon and
okay,
can I see some documentation?
Can I ask you some medical studies?
Like what the fuck are you talking
about?
Like a friend of mine teaches yoga and I
actually had a conversation with her
about it.
I'm like,
you know,
teachers Baker my irregular.
Yeah.
And I was like maybe some teachers
should probably stop saying these things
about like medical stuff because they
teach you that in Bikram Yoga,
like they teach you to say that,
but bikram himself,
he's a fucking crook.
He's a crazy con man and a cult leader
and he's just got sued for like millions
of dollars for sexual harassment and
rape.
Yeah,
I mean he's like,
it may mean allegedly a piece of shit,
you know,
and he's the leader of this whole thing
and somebody explained to me an extra
instructor explain to me why he teaches
bikram yoga and he's like,
look,
the method is very good.
The method of doing it in the hot room,
100,
four degrees,
the poses themselves in that order,
the 90 minutes of them are excellent.
He goes 100 percent believe in the
method of it.
But the method wasn't even created by
beach grove.
That's right.
It's created by another guy in the
thirties.
Yep.
And [inaudible] copywrote it.
But he recently lost a court case where
we see what happens is people get into
yoga,
they say I want to be spiritual,
I want to be healthy.
And they started taking yoga.
Then they find out about this beaker guy
and they go way the fuck.
What the fuck is going on?
Man?
He,
he recently got busted,
right.
Were there,
were there were like trying to like
assess as assets because they were suing
the shit out of him.
All these people that he tried to fuck
or whatever the hell he did,
allegedly,
I don't want to get sued,
but he,
they,
they found he had a warehouse filled
with like Rolls Royce's and Bentley's
and shit and he knows his explanation
was he was going to start an engine in
automotive engineering school for
children and that's why he got these
cars.
That's his fucking explanation.
You got anything?
Stand
kids.
They want to work on large motors.
Only Bentley's on and bentleys or into
bling bling cars.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
Could dip shit.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Well it's amazing because,
you know,
Yoga is,
it can be spiritual,
but it can also be like I,
I used to go to this place called Yaz
and Venice beach and it was yoga and
spinning together.
So you'd get on a spin bike for it was
perfect one hour,
30 minutes on a spin bike and then 30
minutes of like power yoga and you
walked out with like a great cardio
workout stretched out and they didn't
utter a word about anything spiritual
because it was sort of like the antidote
to like be chrome where they're trying
suck you into something.
But I miss,
I miss that little Vinyasa at the end.
I like a little bit of like a meditation
that's led in a really simple way
because it's like you're already in that
almost sub rem state and then physically
you can.
It's just so much easier to go into that
mental you like you've really earned
that,
that a meditation.
Well it's 90 minutes to 90 minutes is
fucking hard to do.
Yeah.
It's hard to do a 90 minute class at 104
degrees restructured now.
But what I find one of the big benefits
of it,
not just physical because there's a
massive physical benefits.
First of all,
my back feels amazing since I've been
doing it.
I've been doing,
it's like real steady every week since
about August,
somewhere around where it was when I
started.
You do it once a week,
sometimes twice a week,
but mostly once a week,
but I'm going to try to do three times a
week what I'm going to try to do now
because of A.
I've dedicated myself to this new diet
and I talked about it a lot and one of
the things I found out is if you talk
about something like on a podcast and
you say,
hey,
for the next 60 days,
I'm not going to have any added sugar.
No grains,
no this,
no that,
like,
you just do it because you've already
said it.
And then other people hear it.
You know the people that listen to the
podcast.
I go,
oh,
well if I can try that too.
And then I hear about all the benefits
these people are having from the Diet
and then I'm like,
all right,
well I'm going to just.
Because if it was just me,
if I said,
oh,
I'll give this a shot,
and then I passed by some place with a
chocolate croissant.
I'm like,
fuck it,
give me that.
Yeah,
no,
but I can't,
so I'm not doing it.
So um,
so when these other people follow,
yeah,
and soon you're going to have a fucking
fleet of Rolls Royces.
My coach free,
no entry fecally,
whatever you want.
Youtube cult.
But the,
my ideas that I'm going to commit to
doing it three days a week because three
days a week it's fucking hard for me.
It's very difficult.
So I'm going to do 60 days of three days
a week to see how that feels.
But the tough thing is I found when I
did it,
I couldn't do shit.
I had like two spots that night and I
was still not 100 percent.
I was a little lightheaded still.
Well we probably need to rehydrate.
You probably needed more water and also
electrolytes.
Somebody telling me got to get a lot of.
Yeah,
you sweat a lot and 100,
four degrees,
you're poor and sweat pouring at the end
of it.
I mean I'm fucking drenched and I have
this huge,
like a thermos that I fill with ice and
water before the class.
Yeah.
The end of it.
It's empty.
Yeah.
The uh,
the idea that I could drink that much
water in 90 minutes.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
And the idea that it just,
I just go right through it.
It's just so hot in there.
But the benefits for your body or
definitely legit,
like my flexibility is fantastic right
now.
My back feels amazing and the big one
though is how shit his rolls off your
back.
Yeah,
like things don't bother me the way they
would bother me if I wasn't doing it.
No Shit.
Yeah,
it's,
it's amazing.
One of the example uses this guy rear
ended my car,
my Porsche.
While you were at a stoplight.
No,
even worse was a,
there was a construction
on the highway and this guy wasn't
fucking paying attention.
He was looking at his phone and he was
from Mexico.
No driver's license,
illegal slams on his brakes,
plows into me with his Honda Civic,
just wrecks his car.
His car was totaled.
My car was actually not that bad.
They just had to replace because
Porsche's actually design their cars it
incredibly well,
and they have this collision bar behind
the engine that accordions when it gets
hit and he completely protected the
engine.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
So it was only like a two week fixed.
I sent it back to shark works in
northern California.
They,
they fixed it.
I had it back in two weeks.
Good as no,
but no compensation from the other
driver.
Uh,
allegedly,
uh,
some insurance,
but most likely no.
But the thing is,
man,
what I saw the guy hit his,
I looked at him,
he wasn't paying attention.
look up,
I saw the look in his eyes,
you know,
like,
you realize like right before he hits
this fucking guy,
he slammed on his brakes right before he
hit.
And luckily he wasn't going too fast
because traffic was going kind of slow.
But um,
I got out and I wasn't upset.
It was weird.
When I fucking love that car.
I mean,
it is a rare car.
There's very few of them.
You can't get them anymore.
Like if you buy them,
they're extremely hard to find and mine
is really rare because it's,
it was done by shark works with this
company in Northern California,
a tell me about shit to it.
So,
but I got out and the first thing I did,
I go up to my ego,
you okay?
And he's like,
yeah,
I'm okay.
I'm like,
okay.
Well we were both okay.
And I swear to God,
man,
I wasn't even upset.
I was not upset.
I was like level.
And it was because I did yoga that day
and I had done it another day that week
that I was just,
I was on my way to the store that was,
was worried about was I was going to
miss my spot because uh,
you know,
I'm,
I usually give myself like I like to get
there like 20 minutes before and I'm
like,
this might fuck me up,
you know.
But I really attribute that to just the,
there's a balance that you get from
doing something like that where you're,
you're exerting yourself extremely hard
for 90 minutes.
It's so fucking difficult and most
people don't know you passed by Yoga
Studios,
you look in there and he got a bunch of
housewives playing with their feet and
they're not doing anything but it's
fucking.
It's a struggle and it's a mental
struggle.
Yeah.
You break through some walls for sure.
And the thing is is I remember I used to
take it up in San Francisco and for
years,
this is 10,
15 years ago,
he's taken up in San Francisco.
I don't know if it was beef from back
then or it was just hot yoga,
but when I tried to leave the studio
because I felt dizzy and nauseous.
Every one of the classes like no you can
do.
It seems like they really encourage you
to breakthrough to get.
It's like a team effort to get through
it.
There's a lot of support in that because
if you're by yourself and you've
experienced that same feeling,
you usually like,
oh,
stop right here.
Yeah,
relaxed,
but you can't stop because everything's
timed.
The teachers timing it and they're,
they're gonna push you through and
everyone else in the class is doing it.
It's a 60 year old lady right next to
me.
She's doing it.
How come I can't do it?
Right?
We all experienced the same thing and
you realize that's the thing about yoga
is like maybe one person might be able
to lift a heavier weight than this
person or they might be able to run
faster,
but the effort that a 60 year old person
puts in versus a 20 year old person is
the same because it's 100 percent.
You're putting in 100 percent effort to
move your body so you might be able to
move more or have more flexibility than
another person,
but the amount of effort you put in is
the same.
Yeah.
So class is never easy because it's
always 100 percent effort,
so it's always fucking difficult.
Well,
and my friend explained to me,
I didn't realize this,
but that each pose is working at
different Oregon,
that you're cleaning out your
progressing,
pressing any fucking Oregon's.
What do you want?
Machine,
annual vice compressing your Oregon.
You toothpaste.
You're stretching and holding it.
Yeah.
That's what you're doing.
Why you're pushing your body.
I mean,
I'm sure there's some sort of benefits
to your Oregon,
you know,
because there's benefits all your
muscles,
your circulation is pumping,
you're sweating like crazy.
It's probably a lot of benefits.
How would you describe the smell of a
beak from Yoga Room?
Like a foot under arm,
butthole,
Vagina,
and then a lot of like anti fungal spray
is.
And a lot of,
um,
you know,
deodorants and like whatever the fuck
they are using to clean it.
Whatever detergent.
Yeah.
You need to let go into the smell.
A little bit tail at first.
That's a wall you get through as well.
The place I go to,
they do a great job of cleaning the
carpets and vacuuming,
but heartbeats frankly shouldn't be a
carpet,
right?
Damn hardwood floor.
But it's too slippery.
Hardwood floors get super slippery and
people follow him.
Fucking rip their knees apart.
I took a shower afterwards and uh,
usually,
you know,
I'm always self conscious in a shower.
I just,
I've nudity it was just not part of my
upbringing at all.
I think again,
Irish Catholic shame and uh,
but my dick was hanging low with that
heat.
It looked good.
My balls were fucking just swing.
And
is it funny that your Dick especially
your balls literally stretches to get
the fuck away from your body?
Like this guy's already eat and let's
get out.
This is to hold back there.
Get away from the asshole.
Yeah.
And then when it's cold at hides because
we got to fucking let us in.
Let us in.
This is one Weirdo who goes to my yoga
class and he always looks at me like I
stole something from him.
Like I don't even know you man.
I didn't do anything.
I always say hi to him and he's always
like reluctant to say hide back when he
comes out of the shower.
He cups his balls and his Dick and no
one can see.
Really?
Yeah.
Like there's something wrong with this
guy.
Well he can cup your both balls and your
Dick with one hand.
Yeah,
he's got it.
I can see why he doesn't want you to see
it but it.
But it's also like he,
he looks at other men,
like they did something to him.
Like I've seen him,
I've watched interact with other men
too.
It's like,
what happened to you,
dude?
This guy just said hi to you and you'll
let you looked at him like he just stole
your fucking girlfriend or something.
It's weird.
It's like sometimes I was just down the
road,
uh,
in uh,
in Addison and you know,
these guys from Texas,
they come up and they're like,
they got on the crisp polo shirt and the
fucking,
you know,
slacks with pleats and the tassels on
there.
Yeah.
And they're real crew cut and they're
fucking built.
And this guy comes up and he right in my
face,
like grabs my hand is like,
how are you doing?
And I go,
I go,
it's okay.
I don't need to buy any insurance today.
Like I get urine Alpha.
You're an alpha.
You're not gay.
I got it.
Take it easy on my hands.
Nice fellow.
So slip on loafers.
Yeah.
People are still buying those double
tassels.
Little bells.
Fucking weird things.
What are those?
The little octopuses that are hanging
from the body,
they don't look good.
They look stupid,
but they're so common.
I know.
It's like there's a style that got
created and just stay stuck with it.
Right.
Like ties.
He had ties the whole idea of dangling a
piece of,
uh,
of material from,
in front of you.
Yeah.
There they are.
Oh my God.
And it's always the.
Why is it always with no socks?
I don't know,
man.
And so these guys with little feet,
you got us.
Your feet must stink in those things at
a stank.
There's no.
Yeah,
there's no way or getting into those
things.
Yeah.
It's leather.
Leather.
You're sweaty ass feet with no socks.
It's almost like what you'd see like a
bagpiper where that's.
It's a weird fetish.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Is this okay?
Dork?
He's texting his girlfriend.
She's getting stuffed with some other
dude.
Just gorilla fucked by.
Some guy she met at the gym while he's
out there getting a manicure.
Well,
I was going to go to the gym,
but my nails are horrendous.
So,
um,
I'll call you later.
We're still gonna.
Do the topless bar and she's just
getting stuff.
What are you going to wear by the way?
I want to make sure it matches what I'm
wearing.
Don't wear blue because I'm wearing
blue.
I'm dressed as Alan,
too generous.
Alan's wife.
I'm just as poor skin dorothy.
Oh yeah,
that's beautiful.
That's great.
The um,
and he only fucks her up the ass.
That's,
that's when you're going to wonder why
you think so.
I like that.
He's just a really.
Yeah,
that's a,
she.
She's only taking up the smes always
like got his hand in front of her pussy
and he's Jack ended up and down.
She's like,
what are you doing?
You're really specific here.
And Eric,
caulk that.
You're chicken.
I'll put my tassels on it.
Need my tonsils were my little first.
I want to feel like we're fucking at the
office.
You don't even work in an office.
Want to.
Don't fuck up the fantasy.
You're normal.
I want to be the executive,
the executive.
I'm sexually harassing.
I want you to assume me.
I'm fucking.
You were fucking.
Because they're kind of promotion.
You don't even have a job.
I got a promotion today,
stop running a promotion,
you get a trust fund.
That world and that world that most
people who are listening to this are
stuck in that world of like trying to
get a promotion,
trying to move your way up the company
ladder,
going to company meetings,
hundreds of people all getting together,
wives and husbands and fucking shaking
hands and wearing your loafers,
loafers and trying to figure out what
church you're supposed to go to to get
ahead what country club to join once she
gets to that next level.
Country Club.
I looked at houses in.
Do you know where Lake Sherwood is now?
Lake Sherwood is an area like way out
near like thousand oaks.
Really Nice,
really nice place and it's a giant
country club,
like a gated community country club.
And uh,
we looked at a house there and um,
when we're there it's like,
like what?
Like,
what is this place like?
This is like,
what's going on in this place?
It's all like people who go there and
they play golf because it's like you,
you to sign up and be a part of the golf
thing.
The golf costs like some insane amount
of money a year.
Like really stupid money.
Like pull that up,
find out how much lake shirt and they're
not going to list it.
A country club,
but I think it's like a quarter million
dollars a year.
Yeah,
like something stupid.
I might be wrong.
Maybe it's 50 grand or something like
that,
but it's something something where you
like,
what were they just trying to keep out?
Anybody who's not stupid wealth,
right?
Does it say it?
Say how much?
One hundred and 85,000
they list.
I thought this clubs would keep that on
the download on their website.
It's the article I found $185,000.
If you want to play golf because think
about if you're a billionaire one 85
doesn't mean shit to you except that
people without it can't get in.
You know,
it's not,
it's not affecting your bottom line.
It's just an insurance policy.
You know,
like,
and then you see these clubs,
like there's a club in Santa Monica,
I forget which one it is,
but you drive past it.
There's never anybody on the chorus.
This is,
this is a miles.
Think about the real estate in Santa
Monica.
If you had a 3000 square foot store,
you'd be paying,
you know,
$10,000
a month for it.
Now take that store,
step it into a golf course that square
miles in that same neighborhood.
What does that possibly work?
And there's nobody playing on the course
to insane.
It's insane.
And the amount of water.
Oh yeah,
the sheer amount of water that gets used
by golf courses,
like they did a,
um,
they had a chart that showed all the
water that's being used by residential
people in houses and you know,
regular folks versus agriculture and
agriculture is just staggering how much
water they use.
But the really nutty one was millions
and millions of gallons.
How many millions are being used by golf
courses just in southern California,
right?
I mean,
it's like a significant percentage of
our water usage is golf.
Yeah.
And
uh,
they write off the land,
they don't have to pay taxes on it as
much as normally because they call it
you're ready for this.
It's like a,
uh,
it's,
it's considered wildlife walk.
Like every city is supposed to have
zoned out a certain amount of
undeveloped land for the environment.
Oh,
golf courses were able to loophole their
way into that so they don't pay them.
It's a wallet preserve,
right?
It's for squirrels.
Squirrels with click and bumps on their
head from getting hit by golf ball
scrolls had been marked by a fucking
blind drive.
Imagine if you're in squirrel,
just hit golf ball bigger than your head
comes 75 miles an hour.
It's like,
wait,
dawn's,
you and Darwin didn't teach me about
this.
How do I react to this in nature?
My friend Ryan got hit in the head by a
long drive and he said he was fucked up
for six months.
Really six months.
He had massive headaches,
so fucking hard ball.
I know too many people that have had
like significant head problems from
getting hit in the head.
Like people always wonder,
like,
why?
I'm always droning on and on about head
trauma and MMA and football and the
dangers of it because I know a lot of
people that one knockout and they're
fucked for like a year.
Yeah,
yeah.
Constant headaches,
constant ringing or year.
My son just got his first concussion.
I play soccer and he got a.
I think he had need and the head and the
collision and he was out of school for a
week.
He couldn't like he'd go to school and
he'd have his head down on his desk and
first beer and have to come home again.
It was bad and it was like,
fuck man,
you don't know when that happens.
A concussion can last a day.
You can last,
like you said,
it could go on and on with with
headaches and it's really important to
recognize that because there's like a
lot of restrictions they put on athletes
after they'd been kod.
Like for fighters.
They'll,
they'll,
you know,
say like no contact for 30 days or 60
days.
Some of them,
but that's not adequate because you
really don't know.
Each individual case of someone getting
knocked out is,
is totally different,
right?
One person get knocked out and they're
fine a couple of days later and then
another person would get knocked down.
They're fucked up for a long time.
Like I got a tk owed once in a
kickboxing fight and I was exhausted.
It was the third fight of the night.
I had fought twice that night before
that flight and part of it was
exhaustion.
I did get clipped with a good left hook
though my legs gave out.
I went down.
I never went out,
but sometimes a punch.
That was weird too because a punch that
jaw.
What happens is it's not even
necessarily your brain,
it's like the nerve behind,
like the nerves,
the ways it's been explained to me.
It's your jaw when it moves can slam
into the nerve and when it slams into
the nerve illich short circuits your
system.
Yeah,
and your legs give out.
It's weird.
Not good for you,
but my point is I was fine after that.
Like I was fine that I was fine the next
day.
I mean,
I wouldn't be a good idea if I had
another fight after that,
but it wasn't like a ringing in my ears
and headaches and those in serious pain,
but at other times just from sparring
sessions where I didn't get knocked out
where my head was pounding for days just
from taking a punch or a kick and you
don't know,
you don't know what day you're going to
be fine or which day you're going to be
fucked.
It all depends entirely on how you get
hit,
how your body responds to it,
what the actual damages and no one you
can't tell unless you get into the
brain.
They really can't tell.
It was amazing is a James Bond will get
knocked out like out somebody you know,
like a bad guy will elbow him and he'll
fucking lose consciousness.
He'll get up and like drive a car,
dance.
Well,
it's pistol whip to.
He gets pissed away,
get pistol whipped in the back of the
head.
They go down,
they wake up,
Oh,
you hit me up and gets going.
That's that pistol whip to the back of
the head move.
It's always effective.
I know you've never killed a guy and and
also when you're fighting a bunch of
people you can pistol whip,
you got to shoot some,
you can piss the whip,
the others and they'll go down and you
just know they're going to stay down
until you're clear to you're outta
there.
When was the first time you saw someone
actually get knocked out?
Who saw how many people you've seen
getting knocked out?
Real life bar fights.
I've seen tons like Kaos.
Yeah.
I've seen cases in Boston,
outside of bars,
street Kales the scariest because they
bounced her head off the concrete.
Yeah,
right.
Things sickening.
Just sickening about the sound of an
unconscious persons head bouncing off
the concrete.
Yeah.
I saw this kid when I was about 17.
I was at a bar and Terry town where I
grew up in this kid,
uh,
he was on it.
He was on stairs,
this bar that had an upstairs and this
one kid was coming up other than was
coming down and they had a beef and the
kid a above just fucking clock.
This guy.
And He fell backwards,
hit his head.
He was in a coma for six months.
Oh my gosh.
Still not 100 percent this,
you know.
I mean,
10 years later,
I haven't seen him since,
but 10 years later the guy was off.
Oh my God.
What happened to the guy who did it to
them?
Went to jail for how long?
It's like three months off.
Nope.
FARC now.
Bar Fights.
No joke,
man.
Kevin James used to work as a bouncer in
a bar and long island guy who was
working with punched a guy.
The guy fell back,
hit his head off the curb and die.
Who?
Yeah,
just fucking bar fight bouncer drunk guy
punches the guy jail,
go to jail.
Jail.
Manslaughter.
Hold.
Wow.
Yeah,
just,
it's no joke.
People think it's a joke.
You know,
it's like you got all these tough guys
that go out to the bars and then you
know,
hey,
we have a fistfight and you know,
it's,
it can end very fucking tragically.
Very fast.
Some
comic at the comedy store got knocked
out like about,
I want to say about a year ago.
Maybe even less.
Yeah,
um,
he was on a motorcycle and he pulled up
to the comedy store and he parked his
motorcycle and um,
I guess he kept it running and some guy
yelled at him,
he met shut that fucking thing off like
they were having a conversation like
over by the patio and he laughed at.
I'm like,
because the guy was like saying that
like really aggressive and he took his
helmet off,
the guy walked over to them and just
fucking cold cocked him and knocked him
out just for having a motorcycle running
shit.
I guess it was one of those who's loud,
like Harley things that people love.
They love those loud.
Right.
But those are loud.
That's good because it saves you from
colliding India if I was a cop,
you know they have like,
they have like a noise meter.
That is my biggest pet peeve.
You're having a conversation on the
street and you have to stop for 20
seconds cause some fucking asshole has
got a muffler that he jacked up to make
that much noise.
Like he's Oh,
who do you powerful?
Oh Shit.
And you feel it in your chest when they
go by,
they're really loud.
Some of those bugs really,
really second only to the truck that has
like that massive horn that makes your
body go paralyzed for like a second.
Like a,
like a dog whistle.
Yeah.
Your body just goes,
what?
Yeah.
Those loud motorcycles though,
like I guess too loud is,
you know,
a problem.
But like a Harley,
like when you buy one from a store
without fucking with it,
that's fine.
But that,
that level of loudness apparently
prevents a lot of accidents because
people hear it and then they avoid you.
Because like part of the problem with
motorcycle accidents,
like say if you have like one of those
Japanese speed bikes,
they don't make that much noise.
So you got to come when you're next to
people so they know you're there because
people are fucking texting and drifting.
How often do you look over and you see
people texting?
Hell yeah.
And I drive a Prius because I'm dead
inside.
But people,
people really can't hear you.
I pulled up today to,
to Valley Park and uh,
the guy's fucking sitting there doing a
crossword puzzle and I'm looking at him
and uh,
and I finally went,
excuse me.
He was like,
oh,
sorry,
I didn't hear Ya.
And it's like,
you feel insignificant already in a
Prius.
He felt castrated and zero.
They don't make any noise.
Like here's me flooring it.
Then your car.
No,
you want to get a nice car.
I can get.
You've been thinking about this for
years.
What holds you back?
I need a little bump of money to justify
it because the college fund isn't there
yet.
I got to get a little,
get a nice little hit,
go out and buy that Mustang.
She's the new ones.
Seen the new ones?
Yeah.
My friend Matt Farah,
like the bank sent me a text.
Apparently the new shelby,
they have a new shelby gt,
3:50
and he just sent me a text about it and
he said he's,
he's emailing everyone who knows it for
just begging them to sell them one
because they're hard to get hard to get
because shelby gt 3:50.
So they have a pr guy that's going to
hook them up,
but he said like literally it is the
best car he's ever driven.
How is it?
I don't know.
Not that expensive though.
It was like less than a lot of cars,
but apparently they're really hard to
get the shelby but you don't need to.
Shelby like a GT Mustang gt.
But one of the cool things about the
horsepower wars,
like here's what's all that white stuff
on it.
Is that just like shininess?
What does that sort of fucked up part of
what the artifact?
Um,
see if you find another one is not on
your screen.
Oh,
it's only when they transferred over to
the television.
How weird,
how fucking strangers that.
There's other images I'm sure you could
find.
But anyway,
the car is a monster,
but a regular Mustang gt.
The thing is a regular one,
like find out how much a regular Mustang
gt is.
I think it's only about,
I want to say it's about 35 grand.
It gets more than that.
I think a regular Mustang just like a
baseline Mustang or you can get for
about 32,
really just don't,
not gt 3:50.
Jamie g just dt.
Ford Mustang Gt.
Yeah.
How much of those pitches cost?
I think like.
Well the thing what I was saying is like
for the amount of look at that 32 grand
for a Mustang gt,
that's fucking crazy.
The amount of power that those things
have and how good they run and how good
they drive.
It's a bargain.
It's an amazing bargain because they
have more than 400 horsepower.
Those things are fast as fuck.
Like what is it?
Four hundred and 30.
What does it say there,
Jamie?
Don't scroll real quick.
What does it say?
Four 35.
Four hundred 35 fucking horsepower.
Four hundred foot pound of Torque for 32
grand.
I mean that's incredible.
And the interior looks good.
They have Ricardo cloth front seats.
I think about what it would've cost to
make a car with those dimensions.
Ten years ago they couldn't do it.
Well,
how about this?
You would.
You would blow the doors off of Ferrari
of 20 years ago with this car was
$32,000
car and it sounds great.
It's a wonderful American v eight and
look great.
I mean I would drive that 100 percent
and it'd be fun.
Those were fun to fucking drive,
man.
Yeah,
it's a great car.
And for 32 grand,
whenever we talk about these things,
people will get mad and they go through
two grooms,
lunar moon and relax.
I gotta get some ads.
Am I uh,
my ads have slowed down on my podcast.
I gotta I gotTa Hook some up if they
slowed down because you haven't pursued
them are now I think my,
uh,
people.
Your ad people are not good that they're
slacking slack and it's hard.
It's hard to do all that shit yourself.
Yeah.
You rely on other people to get it for
you.
They better do their job.
Right.
I'll connect you to my guys after we're
done here.
Yeah,
they're good time.
Yeah.
You got.
The thing is you got to find something
you actually like,
like,
uh,
my favorite ads are like dollar shave
club.
Yeah,
fuck yeah,
dollar shave legit.
It's great.
One hundred percent legit.
I like advertising that I like.
A squarespace is good.
Blue Apron,
blue apron is great.
Fucking less than 10 bucks a meal.
Finding stuff that you.
That's the whole key to it.
Look,
I haven't had a lot of people try to
advertise and I'm like,
Ooh,
I can't get behind that.
One of them was like an uber for
babysitters.
I was like,
get the fuck out of here.
Really crazy gonna.
Have some person come over and watch
the,
the most important person in your life
other than your spouse.
Just randomly.
Randomly because it's cheaper.
Yeah,
they're old.
They're screened like,
yeah,
there's certain things you can't go by
price.
Yeah,
there is a,
yeah,
they,
some that uh,
do you do the betting sites?
Like a draft kings and all that?
Yeah,
I did.
I had him for a long time.
I haven't done one in awhile.
I,
I liked,
I liked the idea behind it,
but some people say that there's issues
with how you get paid.
Oh yeah.
Or not how you get paid rather.
But um,
how many people get paid?
Like when you saying something like
that,
Jamie,
what were you saying?
When I found out about most of it was
like one percent of the players are
making something like 90 to 95 percent
of the money.
Again,
these fucking Goddamn one percent of
white guys,
white guys and knew a lot about sports.
But I feel like if you know and even
understand a lot about like mma and
that's one of the things where,
um,
I like it.
I'm like,
man,
I feel like you could make money.
Like if you're one of those crazy people
that goes on mixed martial arts.com
and you're there every day and know all
the fucking stats,
you know,
what,
excuse me,
watch all the training videos.
You know,
who's trading with WHO and what.
Wow,
this guy has got this new trainer and
it's going to help them with.
I just feel like those guys.
Did you have any inkling about that last
fight?
The two big upsets last week.
Yet,
both of them.
We had a failing on both of them.
They'd be upsets.
No,
I had a feeling that holly could get
beat by Meesha,
but I thought connor was gonna get beat
by nate.
I had a feeling.
I said it to my friends too that were
sitting right behind me.
I took my headset off as they were doing
the introductions.
I said this.
No Shit.
Really?
Yeah,
I could.
Well,
we just saw an upset with me.
She choked holly out and I knew that
Misha was gonna fight.
Real smart in the way she fought,
was super cautious on the outside and
she made holly come to her,
which is not a holly likes to fight.
When Ronda fought,
holly was the perfect fight for holly
because Rhonda charged after like a
maniac and holly just sidestepped
blasted her,
move back,
blasted her.
She just countered her.
And for a person who's a counter
striker,
that style that Rhonda employed is the
perfect style.
Even more perfect for someone like holly
because Rhonda doesn't kick.
So Rhonda has a short range attack,
short range attack,
and on top of that her grappling is
illimited attack because she only likes
to tie up with upper body.
Like Rhonda doesn't take anybody down by
shooting on their legs,
so I knew that holly fighting Misha
would.
She would have a totally different type
of opponent.
First of all,
me,
she's not going to charge out or she's
not.
She's
not reckless.
She's not a fucking crazed maniac.
Like Rhonda wasn't that fight.
Rhonda,
which just started maniacs.
Just want to smash her face in.
Yeah,
you can't find like that.
And meesha fought like super
intelligent,
very cautious state in the outside.
And then once in the second round me got
her down and just dominated on the
ground.
I was like,
oh,
okay.
That my suspicions were correct me,
she can do this.
But then holly pulled it off for the
next couple of rounds and it looked like
holly was going to probably win a
decision if she won the last round.
And then Misha took her down and choked
her unconscious and that was just
madness.
That must've been a payout on picking
the underdogs.
And those two must have been here.
Giant.
I think it was six to one with conor and
nate and I think Misha and holly was
something like three to one.
Yeah,
know my own might've made that up.
I think if you pick them both and bet
100 bucks.
You want something like 1500 bucks
together.
Jamie.
Jamie,
bet on nate and one 500 bucks.
There you go.
Yeah.
Jamie was there where I got a picture of
Jamie,
Tony and my friend frosty the three of
them holding up their betting slips
right after the fight.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
No frosties a sound guy for the UFC.
He's a sound engineer,
but I'm,
I see Jamie taken that Joe Rogan
experience money and fucking Dublin it
down.
Yeah.
There's um,
there's Tony edgecliff to Al.
I saw a great picture of um,
uh,
who was it in the background?
Kissing on the kiss cam.
Oh,
ren duck.
It was fucking great.
Now that before they were kissing,
you were throwing up illuminati signs
and they waited until the fucking camera
was right on them and they turned and
kissed tongue and everything.
By the way,
watch this.
Watch this.
Here it is.
If the camera's on him,
see the boundaries grabbed her face,
like,
what the fuck did we do?
Oh,
that's so bad.
It's like bora doing that cage match
down south that bruno.
Now those guys are animals living there.
This throwing up the illuminati science.
they're probably on mushrooms too.
They get on mushrooms all the time when
they do the ufc because you could sit
there for a long time.
Look at that as a thing about that is
you do it in the moment
what it is funny and then all you're
thinking about is the two dudes that are
sitting behind you the whole time for
the rest of them,
are they going to do that again with the
fact they were sitting in the seats that
are right behind me so they weren't
even.
Audience sees that as a production
seats.
They're sitting in like the best seats
there.
They're three feet from the cage.
They're bright.
They're.
They're like literally,
they could touch me.
They could touch my back.
I was supposed to be at that lab.
We did a gig together in vegas not too
long ago with a fight.
The next day,
and I had to fucking bail.
Dammit.
Cleanouts.
No mustang.
No.
No ring side seats are missing it all.
Oh,
can we plug by the way,
the tomorrow night.
Tomorrow night?
Yeah.
We're,
we're at the improv March 17th st
patrick's day.
Joe rogan joining once again.
I believe you did it last year too.
A couple times,
but yeah,
done a few times.
The st patrick's day show.
We got all irish comics coming down.
Uh,
joel,
mick rogan.
Uh,
karen kill sheriff my gibbons.
We've got a special guest.
I can't even announce.
Huge name guests.
Yeah.
Because you're irish.
A greek.
Okay.
We'll talk later.
All right.
Okay.
That'd be good.
Tickets.
Some tickets left.
Go to the improv.
Always a good time.
Always dab a little irish.
I'm one quarter irish.
That's it.
So it's real.
You're still switched.
Your stolen the show.
Yeah.
They have a party afterwards.
Little corn beef next door and some
irish music and decorations and I'm so
glad they turned the improv around and
have that bar in the front of them.
They had it all wrong for about a year
there.
Will.
They turned it into like some lounge and
encino.
Yeah.
It was like it was white in there and it
was weird.
Dick decorations.
Like,
who designed this?
Yeah.
Now it's darK again and it looks cool.
There was nothing wrong with it in the
first place.
It was perfect before.
Well,
I don't know why they did it just to
leave a good thing alone.
I think they thought they were going to
have a suCcessful restaurant in the
front.
Yeah,
for some reason.
And it didn't pan Out in the restaurant
didn't work out.
They didn't.
Which most restaurants don't.
They say like 90 percent of all
restaurants fail in the first year,
but they got a bag.
It's gReat.
Again,
back to its roots.
That's great.
Club.
Yeah.
AnD I looked at.
They have a second room now.
They have that lab.
You the labs.
Good.
Have you done it?
Fucking great.
Yeah.
It's really just sort of did ari when
that's when he first started his.
This is not happening.
The show that was on last night on
comedy central,
which is on every week now,
um,
before already had that television show.
He started that off in the improv lab,
I think I want to say like six years
ago.
Yeah.
And he's,
his idea was as very smart idea that you
would develop stories better and really
tightened them up if there wasn't
pressure to do like traditional standup.
So like he would do storytelling shows
and they would do them on a theme like
guys who have been arrested or people
that have done too many drugs,
whatever.
And you would do,
he would do a theme on these things and
you go up there and just explore the
story and if you could do that you would
find the funny stuff in there because
you,
it's a different format.
You know,
it's,
you're kind of doing standup.
But then some guys will fuck it up.
Like they'd go up there and they would
just set up punch lines,
just jokes.
But theN like diaz does it right.
Like diaz would tell you these crazy
stories and they would be funny and find
the funny in them.
And a lot of those became bits because
he got comfortable and he did too as
well.
Get comfortable saying them.
And the storytelling format and then
sort of edited down and honed,
sharpened,
didn't
folded the steel,
then it may become a,
a really solid bit,
right.
That's where it starts.
You know,
I got a new bit about uh,
seeing a couple of fucking in the hotel
room across from me.
Yeah.
it was fucking amazing.
I mean,
I won't do the bid.
I'll tell you,
the story has now turned into a bit
debt.
Fucking crushes.
I mean it went from you to have.
Sometimes you get a new bit and it can
take three months to become your closing
bit because you're still working out
this thing raced to closing bit in like
five tellings of it really.
So I won't do the bit,
but I'll tell you the story which is
basically near year's.
Even portland,
the hotel Is like a horseshoe shape.
So I'm on the 10th floor and I look
across into a room and the curtains are
open,
lights are on,
chick is on her back,
legs up.
And this dude who's ripped his fucking
pounding her and I'm just standing there
looking at him like,
like this is the greatest thing I've
ever,
greatest things that ever happened.
I got,
I slept my bag in my hand and I'm just
transfixed and they're,
you know,
they're really fucking.
And at one point he,
uh,
he,
he's,
he goes down on one knee,
eats or out stands up,
keeps fucking.
I'm like high five in the glass,
like go.
And then.
And so I had the curtain closed because
I didn't want them to see me,
but I popped my head through the curt,
I looked like a photographer from the 19
thirties.
And then I start thinking about what it
must sound like.
And this a sound.
This where it gets creepy,
creepy air is I leave my room.
I walked down the hall and I stand
outside the room and I listen and I hear
him grunting and I hear her go to my
room and I call.
I call the room.
Just watching him waiting,
waiting.
And he didn't pick up that.
If he did,
I would have been like,
yeah,
but what's better than some free nudity?
Like you didn't earn it.
You didn't have to void.
Take anyone out to dinner.
You didn't have to go to a strip club.
You just,
you just see some nudity in a window.
Well,
it's way more exciting for sure.
Accidental nudity is way more exciting.
The voice,
this avoider instinct that all of us
have for whatever reason.
I don't know why,
you know?
That's why like,
like those Jennifer Lawrence leaks,
sex pigs,
she knows.
She sent that to her boyfriend.
Like oh my god.
It's her like spreading her cheeks and
like Jennifer Lawrence showing her pussy
and asshole and taken a thick one of the
face.
Did you see that one?
But I don't like even looking down at a
woman's shirt.
Yeah.
My mother in law was doing the dishes at
our house.
She's wearing a nightgown.
Bent over and looked down her shirt.
Bad.
so fucking gross.
Oh,
how old was he at the time?
70 slash 30.
You know what?
They were full.
They were full and they weren't
wrinkled.
And I thought this is what my,
what my wife's tits are gonna look like
in 25 years,
unless she gets on that college and man
is going to be great for everyone.
Duck duck,
duck,
duck.
It's going to be weird,
man.
Gonna see 80 year old hot ladies.
Yeah,
it's going to smell like a two year old.
So once they opened their mouth,
smelled tombs.
It's,
that's come flying out of there.
Fucking flies like that.
I just walk into a bikram yoga studio.
It'd be nice if you had an expiration
date.
You'll work up to that date and
everything worked awesome up until that
date.
And then into the great aByss.
I think that should be an option.
I think that you should have total
coverage for your health.
You know,
talk about universal healthcare,
fucking blue,
blue cross to the nth degree.
Everything you need,
$1 copay,
whatever.
But then when you turn 73,
they just come,
you're sleeping one bolt to the back of
the head or you get a minimal policy.
Lot of copay,
big deductible.
But you get it for the rest of your life
as long as you live.
Yeah.
But the shooting you in the head part,
Why do they have to shoot you in the
head of 73?
[inaudible] you.
You'll be a drain on the system and just
pay more money now because that money
has to go back into the system.
YeaH.
But you're earning money for alive now.
Seventy four.
No.
Maybe you're one of those warren buffet
type characters.
Still out there hustling.
That's true.
Do hustle loom.
You know he lIves in omaha,
Nebraska.
Sand hills.
He first had his kids in.
Now.
How's that possible coach?
How's nobody robbing him?
Right?
He flies.
Coach.
I believe so.
Or maybe that was sam walton that flies
coach sam walton used to fly coach.
My only problem with that is why have
all that money then?
What's he doing with it?
If I,
if I would think there's one thing you
want to pay for the cost a little extra,
it's it's business class.
It makes a flight from exhausting and
aggravating to relaxing and like if
you're in first class,
you don't want to get off the fucking
plane.
When you land,
you're sitting there,
you're watching a good movie,
you get some soft leather wrapped around
your dirty ass hole and you just got a
little mimosa.
You're talking to interesting wealthy
people sometimes.
Sometimes unit.
You're true to offer more on.
Yeah,
that's true.
I can happen to.
That should be part of for his class is
just a fucking little urinal divider
comes up in between you and that guy.
As soon as someone starts talking to
you,
just
look at your eyes slowly.
Yeah.
There's some people you sit next to.
It's great,
but you can't choose.
Oh,
I was on the fucking plane the other day
headed back from vegas and there was a
drunk guy that was doing air quotes
business on the phone and he was so
loud.
Tony and I were like,
what the fuck?
and he was like,
who?
Basically the bottom line is if we get
this account,
we are set and he's drunk and he's being
real.
I think maybe he was doing it to let
everyone know that he's doing because he
was definitely hammered.
The plane takes off and then within five
minutes of the flight being the air out
cold,
snoring just drunk off his ass.
Probably stayed up all night,
got a flight,
pig alcohol.
He had seven runaway grinding on his
cock to a van halen song about three
hours earlier.
That's the good part.
Panama Panama just rocked out.
This van halen driving over here.
They came on the a sirius xm and eddie
van halen is one of the greatest guitar
players ever of all time.
Unquestionably is a bad motherfucker.
Yeah,
but valerie bertinelli.
Malley and prime.
Yeah.
That wreck.
That band though,
did she?
which she did.
She yoko it,
yeah.
Oh,
I didn't know that was.
Yeah,
that's what David Lee roth.
That's big part of why David Lee roth
jettisoned during the prime days and
then they turned it to sam hagar didn't
enjoy one of those songs.
It was a different band.
Yeah.
It's weird because like I,
it was still super successful and maybe
even more successful with sammy hagar
than it was with David Lee roth,
but man,
it was not the same because different
band entirely.
It was all,
it was weird.
It was weird.
It's not like acdc which just smoothly
transitioned.
Yeah,
like you can't even tell you go listen
to old acdc and then the new singer acdc
when that's,
which is old still now,
but it's all ecdc van halen to fucking
massively different bands,
but just like that poppy bullshitty
stuff that became massively,
massively successful.
Well,
it was like guys trying to be hard
rockers.
It was,
it was like they were playing a
character.
That's what sammy hagar always seemed
like to me.
You can't drive 55 really can't even if
there's a cop on the side of the road,
you'd like literally have to speed past
the 55.
It a bullshit speed limit though.
That's why they got rid of it.
It's really 65 now,
but I mean if it says 65,
you can go 74.
You won't get pulled over.
You might want a porsche,
you will.
You can get pulled over.
You're a.
You're a a lightening rod and that thing
in any kind of car though,
if you're going 10 miles an hour over,
they can get you.
Not a press.
Really.
How
they just look at you on.
They feel so bad for you.
Bastard car doesn't even make noise.
I can't believe he goes,
I'm proud of you.
It's rolling down the hill like I'm
fucking hot.
Wheels.
Car.
Look,
he's got golf clubs in the back.
How much?
HOw many gallons?
The gas.
How many miles to the gallon do yet?
You want to hear the sad part is this a
button that you can push on your prius
that that takes all the electricity off
so that you just drive with the gas,
but it makes you like way faster and I
pushed that every time so I don't even
really get the savings.
Really.
It takes away now.
I don't know if it completely does,
but it gives you.
I'm telling you,
it is a quick car.
If you don't,
if you don't have the electricity thing
turned on because it's so fucking light
and aerodynamic,
quick telling you I line up on the
fucking at a red light.
I line up against a mustang gts and they
just don't try to try or a prius.
That's right.
We,
we,
we raised for pink slips.
Well,
it's also has no gears,
right?
Just no gear one gear one fast.
Slow,
fast,
slow.
Yep.
How,
like if you fill your tank up with gas,
how long does it last?
I don't drive a lot.
I live on the west side.
I felt,
you know,
I drive three miles at a time.
Do you still miss venice?
Still miss Being in that little tight
knit community?
Well,
you know,
I'm only a mile away.
right?
But uh,
I'm,
I'm there.
Yeah I miss it a lot.
It makes my quality of life is about 30
percent worse.
Not living in that neighborhood.
I used to walk my dog and say how to
seven people,
which I know we've talked about.
You don't love that.
I love that.
I like to be in contact with people.
I like to walk into houses.
Well,
it was like,
you know,
if you know on my block was duncan reu
cowen,
joey diaz,
we'd have a fucking great time.
It will be against the goal,
a sack and all by house.
We'd have to all agree to live together.
Yeah.
We'd have to all find a spot that we all
agree to and.
But if you could engineer that,
that would be the pool and they have
like a rec room where there's a pool
table and a ping pong table documented
don steam room.
You got to do is you've got to buy like
a giant piece of land and then develop
on it.
Right.
Develop your own little gated community.
Yep.
Call it a church.
Don't pay taxes.
Fuck all of each other's wives.
Right?
What?
Yeah,
that's what I do.
Take an acid koolaid,
whatever.
We got to do bikram yoga every morning.
Yoga.
We'll bring them in and he'll,
he'll be the leader.
Bring them,
put them on the hill.
Who started automotive engineering
school.
There was warehouse.
Yeah.
Our kids will all Be fucking mechanics.
rolls royces.
Yeah.
Was anybody ever,
you know who's done that?
This guy,
uriah faber,
who's a former wec champion,
he's fighting for the ufc bantamweight
title.
Great guy.
HumaN is a lot of his fighters.
They have a house on a cul de sac,
they call it the block,
bought a few houses in this area.
Swan,
one area because he buys and flips
houses.
It's one of his side side gigs.
He buys houses and I believe his dad
does construction.
His dad like refurbishes these houses
and sells them.
So they bought some houses all on the
same block and while he was a,
I think new year's eve,
some girl broke into his house,
um,
shit all over the place.
Threw up like some girl that didn't even
know she was hammered and she broke into
his house and he like,
uh,
I think he filmed it and put it on
youtube or like put it on instagram or
something like security cameras caught
it or he know he was there.
He was There.
This girl that came into his house and
she was just completely smashed.
He had no idea who she was.
So he just pulled out his ceiling,
started videotaping,
find that.
Yeah.
Just as an experiment.
Like let's see what she'll do.
Well,
I think he was like,
um,
this is not your house.
You have to leave.
And she was just so fucking smashed.
You didn't know where she was.
He could have been done to huxtable that
night.
Well,
I think she was relatively large.
Yeah.
Here it is.
Uriah favorites.
There was other guys there.
Yeah.
She locked herself in his bathroom.
So he's um,
he's walking with his phone to the
bathroom.
See If you can skip through a lot of
this.
They,
he's got it right to show this because
it's his house.
Oh,
the cops showed up.
Now the cops are gonna kick the edited
videos.
You don't have to get stuff.
Oh,
I see.
Do you do snapchat?
Do you have a snapchat?
I am not sure if I have it or not.
I do not have a snapshot.
But people liked that shit to snapchat.
Snapchat when it goes up and then you
watch it and it comes down,
it goes away after a while.
Why would you want it to go away though?
I'm not sure.
I think you can keep it if you want.
You can make it stay there and it
becomes like a story or something.
That's the new thing with all.
There's too many to periscope.
I have periscoped.
I stopped periscoping,
did it for awhile,
but I'm on brody stevens all the time.
You see him all the time.
periscopes,
every the greatest.
He puts his iphone on the holster and
like periscopes on his way to work on
his way to the store,
right?
Just talking.
Well joey diaz doing the morning smoke.
That's the greatest.
That's the greatest joe.
He gets up every morning and just,
I think he doesn't like 7:00
in the morning.
Smokes a joint and started talking.
It gives you the motivation.
Motivational insight from uncle joey
come on in motherfuckers and he gets ah,
like ridiculously high and he's doing it
on camera.
You just keep seeing him hitting it and
spoken.
That was one of the ones.
Where is he?
Uh,
he explained his beef with john capullo.
He had a beef with and keppra all.
Oh my god.
Legendary,
yeah,
play it played out on twitter where
they're both going back and forth with
each other.
Yeah.
And then it played out at the comedy
store or joey apparently,
and him got into some sort of an
altercation recently.
Physical joey spit in his face I think.
Was it a joke thief thing?
No,
no.
You would have to talk to both of them
for to be,
for me to be fair for me to give you a
real assessment of what happened,
but essentially it was his job,
his contention that john was trying to
control the lineups and keep certain
people from performing and ale that he
fucked over the comedians doing so john
copper rule denies this and it says that
joe is a bully and a prison yard asshole
and that kind of shit.
And so,
you know,
obviously my loyalTies with joey
joey sat all the way,
always thought capra.
I don't know what that guy did to me one
time.
Capullo yeah.
What'd he do?
He asked me,
can I be on your podcast?
And I'm like,
alright,
whatever.
So I give them a date time.
We come up with a date and a time and
then uh,
like it's 11:00
and uh,
he,
uh,
I email him like,
where are you?
He's like,
oh,
uh,
I'm on my way,
but there's really thick traffic on the
four.
Oh,
five.
And I looked,
you know,
I look it up on,
I maps this fucking.
It's all green.
Everything's great.
It's a pasture is no red lines.
And so I go,
all right,
well I'm here,
come whenever and then he emails me back
like 20 minutes,
like I'm fucking wasted my whole day.
And he's like,
uh,
it's not geographically optimal for me
right now.
And Uh,
but I'm Free all day if you want to Come
into my house,
come to my house in the valley.
And I was just like,
delete.
Why?
Yeah.
Hm.
How odd.
Hmm.
I don't want to feed into a beef here.
Yeah,
I don't think you are,
but I think you're,
you know,
there's something going on there that's
something weird.
Kind of controlling.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It might.
Who knows?
We could talk off air.
I could speculate with you off air
involving all sorts of various things
that people might get really excited
about doing lot.
A lot of speculation.
He said I never had a problem with them.
I never.
I've never had a problem with them.
I don't know.
Now he's a good guy.
He thinks though that I somehow or
another I'm involved in this and so his
paranoia is fed into.
He thinks that joey diaz is my hitman
and then somehow or another I'm plotting
against him,
which I don't even understand.
Why wouLd do that?
Like why I don't even.
I
don't know why I don't.
I don't get it.
Oh man.
Some people,
they tripped themselves.
Oh absolutely.
and the thing is about the comedy store.
As much as I love it,
sometimes that,
that shit gets.
It gets a little school yardi
not as much anymore,
man.
Tommy's gone.
Yeah.
I mean this is also because john was
friends with tommy and that's also part
of joey's contention is that he pulled
up with tommy to control that place.
I don't know.
I don't give a fuck.
I go tell my jokes.
I say hi to people like you and hang out
with my friends.
I don't want to be involved.
I don't get to take 20 minutes early.
Say what's up?
All that shit is just a waste of time.
There's a lot of people out there that
are living their lives.
Just sort of going with the momentum of
all these things that people have to do,
all the gossipy things and get involved
in controlling this thing about
yourself.
Just think about what you're doing.
Don't get distracted and I can.
I think a lot of that is a distraction.
A lot of the people's fixating on other
people at this fucking guy.
He's doing this so that fucking guy
doing that and man,
he fucking why you need something funny
was you getting on before me?
That is all distractions and it keeps
you from thinking about yourself.
There's a lot of people had to spend a
tremendous amount of time hating on
other people and very little time
working on themselves and it's a fucking
trap.
It's an easy trap to get into because
it's.
It's,
there's no,
there's no commitment to hating on
someone.
You don't,
there's no consequences if it doesn't go
well.
So you put your energy into that and you
know,
almost like you're like hoping they fail
so that it justifies this idea that you
have in your head,
but you're not,
you're not benefiting
and it's wasting.
You can waste a day,
you can still about something and all of
a sudden it's the end of the day and
that was shit that you want it to
accomplish that you didn't do because
you were obsessed with fucking googling
the person and finding out if it's a
story that people are latching onto.
This whole thing with joey,
I'm sure it's wasted more of his time
that he wanted it to.
Yeah,
but he put it on periscope and it's
pretty amazing.
he did.
Yeah.
And he's smoking pot while he's talking
about.
Let me explain to you what that did.
I don't know.
Ah,
why do people love it so much?
No,
I don't know.
Why do I love it?
I don't love it with everybody though.
With joey.
It's just entertaining.
Yeah.
I don't know why.
I love him so much when,
when he's involved in something I'm
involved with,
I like it or not,
I have to be,
you know,
but it's um,
there's a lot of wasted energy is my
point,
you know,
and even with joe,
he's,
he's done with it now.
He won't even talk about it now.
Bring it up now.
It was,
I don't give a fuck.
Joe rogan,
I murdered them at san jose.
He's just out there smashing.
He's hit a whole new level recently to
has he.
Oh my
god,
he's got this bit I don't want,
I don't want to give up any of the
details of the bit,
but he's got this bit where it just
like,
I'm just like the frenzy that he
approaches this bit with on stage.
So like,
wow,
he's on another level.
He's like hitting new levels.
Well,
I,
I had to follow him at the,
uh,
in the main room of the store recently
and he went up and he,
people were doubled over.
They couldn't even make noise.
It was,
it was just cruel what he did to this
audience.
And then,
you know,
in the,
in a comedy story,
each act brings up the next act.
So he introduces me and then I come up
and he shakes my hand and he whispers in
my ear.
Sorry dude.
No,
I couldn't follow it right out of the
gate.
Oh yeah man,
he's a monster.
Yeah.
He murdered in vegas and I was with him
in vegas two weeks ago.
A coffee at or 2000 people.
It's fucking de Roy Roy.
He's a monster.
He's just a,
he's hit this level right now where he's
just so free and loose and he's
concentrating on standup so much.
He's really into it,
you know,
and he's reaping the rewards.
Like finally people recognizing like he
sells out everywhere now I can advance.
So finally people are recognizing how
talented he is and how dedicated is.
I mean it's really just one of those
examples of focus and attention.
Equally results,
focusing on something,
really honing it and really putting your
focus and your attention on something.
And then seeing the results of it.
He's just really passionate right now
about stand up.
He's always been.
But right now because he's getting so
much love and he's just,
he's just constantly selling out
everywhere,
crushing it.
So he's like really like feeling
energized or went through the same
thing.
He just put massive focus on,
you know,
he just one of those guys,
he,
you know,
he would put writing and performing
ahead of other things.
It'd be like,
hey man,
and do a podcast.
I can't for the next two months,
I'm just focusing on standup.
That's a.
Well that's the way to do it,
right?
I mean you can always focus more.
Right?
And I think for me the balance has
always been focusing so much that I lose
some passion for it.
You know,
like,
like sometimes I take a couple of days
off and I come back hot juvenate it,
like last night was really fucking fun.
We did this benefit.
Brian cowen had a benefit last night.
We did it in the main room and so last
night was tuesday,
so I didn't work sunday or monday,
so taking sunday or monday off.
I came in tuesday like fired up.
But it's nice you get like.
So I think there's this balance of like
letting it go,
living life and then concentrating again
coming back at it.
Like if you grow it's like grinding too
much is not good either becAuse then you
lose a little bit of focus.
It's like this weird balance to achieve
is also a balance between the
road and in town.
Like if I go on the ride just to three
weeks in a row on the road I came back,
I took off like you know,
for four days or something.
and then when I went out it was like
when you had been running with weights
and all of a sudden you're like doing a
10 whatever,
15 minute spot at the comedy store in
front of a hot crowd.
And it was like just fucking effortless.
it was like you were floating above the
room going like,
yeah,
now I'll do,
I'll throw this in,
I'll throw like,
just toying with them having such a
blast.
We know it's also those long sets that
you do on the road.
That's what brings everything together.
Yeah.
When you do in like a headlining set and
you're doing an hour and 10 and just
some just sort of sorting it all out and
putting it all together and you get
loose and you just do it like friday
night,
two shows,
saturday two shows and then it gets just
so smooth.
Comedy is in a lot of ways like
exercise,
you know,
you definitely shape.
You get in shape for it.
Yeah.
And also like exercise,
you need recovery right?
When we were young we didn't recover.
I mean I used to work six,
seven nights a week every week,
year round and I kind of need that when
you're starting out.
Well we were so we were like colt right
out of there,
out of the horses,
pussy.
We just didn't know how to walk or get
on stage to get our stage legs.
You know,
that's a.
I don't know,
it's a strange thing,
comedy,
because you really think was after all
these years that you would have it down,
but you don't really.
You always,
you're always geTting better.
you always have to stay on top of it.
Never a,
I wonder if music is like that.
I wonder if.
I guess it must be because musicians are
notorious for their practice.
Yeah.
That's one thing that I think I kind of
envy about musicians,
like they have to be disciplined.
They have to practice.
they can't practice in front of a crowd.
I think can't go in front of a crowd
with a half ass song and hope it comes
together because the crowds hot.
Yeah.
You know,
he can't talk to the crowd halfway
through because you didn't finish
writing.
Yeah.
Like,
uh,
someone said something about ian
edwards,
like,
uh,
you know,
the ian,
like,
oh man,
he's fucking writing.
He's always writing.
He's always putting stuff together.
Like,
yeah,
shouldn'T we all be doing that man?
Like,
yeah,
I guess.
So he was like,
hey,
guess what?
I like to write on stage.
Well,
yeah,
because it's fucking easier that way.
You go onstage with a halfass premise
and you're forced to kind of put it
together.
Yeah.
It's just fear that keeps you from
sitting down and doing it.
I think people feel like maybe they're
not that strong of a writer and there
they sit down and they're almost afraid
that it won't come together,
but then when you have the energy of
being onstage,
then you know,
you can,
you can use that.
BuT um,
it's just,
it's slower,
you know,
writing off stage,
it takes longer because you're just not,
you're energy is not as high,
but you can lay down the idea at least
in the structure and then maybe it'll
get funnier on stage,
but you can't start from scratch.
Some people can,
some people do,
buT I think everybody would benefit from
both.
Right?
I think everybody would benefit from ad
living on stage and everybody would
benefit from writing more.
That's what I try to tell young comics.
I'm like,
man,
you force yourself to write.
Even if you only write an hour a day to
sit down for an hour a day,
just force yourself to go over some
ideas and they will blossom and they
will fucking find a way to make it out
to that stage.
And they may not right away sometimes,
like,
I haven't done this in awhile,
but I bought a note book about a month
ago.
I started writing long hand again,
you know,
read the paper for a little while or
just muse listened to sets that I did on
stage and maybe I started a little
tangent and you know,
write that up and I just fucking fill in
this notebook and it's not all making it
right into my act,
but some of it is,
some of it goes into the podcast.
It's kind of like just a running journal
that I can draw from.
But I've had bits that I've started a
year before and pounded it,
believed in it,
kept trying to try to hit my head
against what doesn't work.
And then you pick it up against six
months ago and it just click.
It's like you found it,
but it has to sit late in your brain
sometimes for it to work.
Yeah.
SomeTimes a thing can happen in life and
that thing in life opens up a door like
and you go,
oh,
I could approach it this way.
or,
oh,
I'm looking at it the wrong way,
or oh,
of course it's this,
you know,
and I think that's the same way with any
kind of creative writing.
Anything,
whether you're writing stories,
you're writing a blog,
like sometimes you just have to go
outside of it,
you write some stuff down,
then you go outside of it live your life
and then reapproach it.
Yeah.
And then like every day my perspective
shifts at least a little bit.
You know,
you have like core values and things you
believe in and things you,
you,
you agree with and don't agree with,
but every day like some things will
happen in life that make you look at
things a little bit of a different way,
you know,
especially when it comes to current
events and politics in the world.
And lIke everyday,
like people go,
oh man,
you were so wishy washy with some of
your ideas.
Well yeah,
they,
they're flexible,
they're moving around a lot and
especially when it comes to things that
are happening in the world.
And I think sometimes you just gotta
like,
like let those things.
Like let let your thoughts sort of roll
around without trying to constantly
define them and then reapproach the
idea.
Then come back to the,
to the,
to the original notebook or the original
piece that you wrote and look at it
again maybe a week later and go,
well now that I've experienced a couple
of things in life this week and look at
the world a little bit.
One of the things that tom seger and
christina palicki do,
We had a conversation that christina and
I the other day,
she said that they used to do their
podcast twice a week and decided to Go
back to doing it once a week and I was
like,
how come?
And she goes,
I think it's good to live to live your
life and then have some shit to talk
about.
Like if you do too many of them,
then sometimes you,
you're just talking shit and doesn't
doesn't necessarily mean to you.
Well,
especially because for them it's about
their relationship and what's in it.
So
you know,
they're not bringing in a new guest who
can bring new ideas.
they're talking about their life.
Well,
they occasionally have guests,
but yeah,
for the most part,
yeah.
That's the way to avoid it is to have
guests.
Right.
People were selling.
How do you talk to people for three
hours,
five days a week?
Well,
they're fucking interesting people and
it's not hard just you just have cool
conversations.
Yeah,
right now.
But if you don't,
if you just do it yourself,
like bill burroughs and most amazing
one.
Yeah.
Because bill doesn't even have a fucking
guest.
Yeah.
And he,
uh,
he's got a couple of ideas and some
shit.
He wants to talk about some things that
happened,
but he just rambles.
Yeah.
By himself.
I started doing a thing.
I've done about five of them now called
the sunday papers where I just,
I get the sunday paper and I read it and
I just make some notes and then I just
hit,
hit record and I go for an hour.
That's a sunday paper.
I'm going to do one.
I'm going to be on vacation this week
after this weekend and when I go on
vacation from doing the podcast,
I'm going to put up like a little
instagram question mark and I'm gonna
say just asked me some questions,
throw some questions that I'm just
answer some of the questions on the
phone.
I'm going to be on vacation with the
family.
Yes,
my friend.
Yeah,
there you go.
I'll need more of that right now in this
life.
More.
Relax.
You ever gone to Colorado next week?
Ski I thought were going to say get
high.
Get high.
Well,
I'll probably get.
Hi.
I'm doing shows,
but then we're going to get a less key
after that.
Which part?
Aspen.
I don't know.
We just kInd of a rented a car.
We'll go get.
Get on 70 west.
Maybe stop and breckenridge or maybe go
to vail.
I know already.
Just went to vail.
his broke his ankle.
Broke his ankle out there.
Yeah,
flux game.
Oh really?
You're not a scare.
I learned it pretty hard last time I
went.
Yeah.
A couple of months ago,
not even a month ago.
Month ago.
Wiped shin bone and I was at and you
just said,
I'm done with this.
Like this is so ridiculous.
Why do things that are more fun?
Yeah.
I do a lot of things that are really
fun,
so skiing is like,
don't get hurt,
don't get hurt.
Don't dad.
No,
that's who we go bowling.
That's true.
it's almost like the entire.
The entire aDventure is based on not
breaking something.
It's like the tension between.
Yeah,
the scenery is nice and all that,
but really you're thinking don't get
hurt.
Yeah.
I mean I get it,
I get it and it's a fun time for me to
be with my family.
Yeah,
it's fun.
It's fun.
The kids love skiing.
It's a good time.
I don't mind doing it.
Puts just got to slow down.
Where are you going fast?
I wasn't even going that fast.
I Called a little bit faster than it
should,
but you catch an edge.
I don't know what happened.
I don't remember what happened,
but I remember as I was falling going,
oh,
this one might be a bad one.
Yeah,
I'm good at rolliNg though.
Like I know how to not fall too bad,
so I was fine,
but I was like,
ooh.
That was a hard hit.
Yeah,
I,
I walked out of it.
No probleM.
Put my ski back on.
Skied down the mountain.
He has fun,
but it like,
people get fucked up doing this.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I get carried away too.
You're supposed to wear a helmet.
I wear a helmet.
Oh you do?
No.
Yeah.
You doN't know really?
Maybe I will wear a helmet.
Right?
My friend got knocked the fuck out last
year.
Snowboarding and he was jack for awhile.
Um.
Yeah.
He just fucking woopsies landed
completely on his head.
His feet went up in the air and he just
boom.
Headfirst all head back or front
somewhere.
He doesn't know.
He went out shit.
Yeah,
just thump.
Yeah.
And by the way,
that thumb could be thump.
Snap.
Oh,
guess what?
Now you're moving around with a straw.
You have a strong rather.
And that's how you navigate through
life.
Yeah.
All because you were into like a thrill.
Well,
what abOut the scan and trees going
between the trees?
Where it's grooves you're going between
trees and where your skis go are like
deep grooves that your ski has to go
directly into and if you catch an edge
you flip over like a fucking tree.
I mean,
I get it,
I get the people like it,
but like,
um,
my friend aubrey is good friends with
bodie miller.
He's the olympic ski guy.
Just mangled his fucking leg.
Yeah.
He just wiped out and crashed into
something and just fucked his leg up.
Take us 60 miles an hour.
Jesus christ,
but make even guys are that good still
wipe out fuck themselves out.
Yeah.
It just seems like there's a lot of fun
shit that I like to do that.
Like that's one of the reasons why I
didn't start skiing until late in life
because I did jujitsu and all these
other things that already are dangerous
for your body.
And I'm like,
it's probably like limit the amount of
dangerous shit.
That's why I wouldn't ride a motorcycle.
I'm like,
it's probably back off of that.
Yeah.
I started playing ice hockey again a few
weeks ago.
Get comedians got a little league gulen.
Bill supposed to be good,
right?
Yeah.
He plays in it.
And steve byrne and ian,
great exercise.
You know,
it's not dangerous because we don't hit
each other and you don't really ever
fuck up a knee or an ankle and hockey
because it's ice.
You slide,
you know,
it doesn't stick and turn.
You just kind of slide.
And so unless you trip and fall into a
wall,
you're pretty safe.
Bobby or mangled nice man.
Daddy,
bobby or used to come to the gym that I
worked at when I was a kid.
I worked aT the boston athletic center,
which was the boston athletic club,
I guess it was.
And that was,
um,
I was 18,
I guess 18,
19,
something like that.
And um,
bobby or was this legend,
you know,
this hockey legend.
He was an older by then,
you know,
long retired,
but he would come into the gym and he
couldn't even fucking walk and we would
have to help him climb onto the
versaclimber,
you know,
the versaclimber that pole and you go up
and down and down with.
You'd have to help him pick his legs up
because his knees don't bash.
They don't.
They don't completely lock out and
they'll completely bend.
It's like this.
So it's like the one thing he can do in
the gym.
Yeah.
He goes from this like,
um,
like from completely straight.
He's like five degrees.
Like ben,
he's always bent and then it only goes
to like maybe 15 degrees.
Yeah.
It's like this tiny amount of bend that
he hasn't because he's had just massive
surgeries all through his knees.
What you watch them walk,
there's his knee.
Damn.
With all the cuts on his knees.
And by the way,
that is,
uh,
that's back in the olden days and look
at the different operations.
Seventy three,
72,
71.
Oh,
69,
1970.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
You know how bad the equipment was back
then?
The skates were like a saws.
The skates were bad and the surgeries
were terrible.
TheY didn't know how to fix you and
would fix you and you just go,
right.
We'll look at,
go up up above that.
You could see his knee like that.
Yeah.
Look at that fucking thing.
Jesus christ.
That is brutal.
It Was awful.
Oh,
is it someone else's name?
his,
uh,
just watching him walk and he would play
racquetball and I'd watched him play
racquetball and he would just fall down.
Yeah.
He would just like try to like,
move forward and he just fall is,
couldn't move.
Yeah.
I mean he was basically left with pegs
that barely bent.
Yeah.
And that's how he got around.
It's like left,
right?
Peg,
right peg.
Left pay.
Yeah.
Lot of hockey players or they play golf,
you know,
they retire and they play a lot of golf.
That's like a big sports in Canada or
golf and hockey.
Same swank.
Slapshot in a golf swing are pretty
similar.
oh,
that's happy madison.
Right?
Right.
That's why.
That's right.
See Israel Israel science behind it.
But uh,
no,
I,
I think that a football players are the
worst.
Those guys you see any football player
after they finished playing and they're
fucking stumbling around.
Yeah.
They're mangled.
Some of them not,
you know,
it's interesting.
Some of them are really lucid.
They get through like michael irvin.
michael irvin is super lucid.
You've got no problems.
I mean maybe he's banged up a little
bit,
but he can walk around.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
he's fine.
He looks great.
Talks great.
Yeah.
He's an interesting guy.
Matt.
very fucking smart dude.
Yeah,
very smart guy.
Big ufc fan.
I talked to them all autonomouS.
Seem at the matches,
so no shit.
Fantastic guy.
Wow.
Does he do sPortscasting?
Um,
I'm sure he does.
Does he?
Yeah,
jamie's knows.
And sunday morning stuff.
Yeah.
With that.
Uh,
I think the guy michael strahan,
that guy from that show,
he.
Yeah.
He's so annoying.
Why is he doing?
He's just trying so hard to be likable.
I just don't buy it.
It just feels hollow anD we.
Well,
I love that.
Kelly late.
I could watch her all fucking day.
That's why you don't like them to think
he's saving the dicker way.
If I don't like the black white
relationships in general,
disturb you.
They Just feel wrong.
I mean,
I was boRn in [inaudible] 66 when things
are normal because back in the olden
days before the colors mixed,
when a man could get water from a
drinking fountain and not worry about
it.
Do you think he's given her the dick?
I don't,
but I.
And it's not sexual with her.
It is sexual,
but it's also,
I think that she is really.
You're fucking.
No I don't.
I'd look at that fake smiles.
I really don't like them,
you know?
Do you really have a problem with black
white relationships?
Not really right now,
but I have a problem with his phoniness
and just that she deserves better.
She deserves regis.
Regis was the best regis in her.
That's part of my problem is regis
withdrawal will read this is doing other
shit now.
Like he didn't stop working.
He had to life though,
man.
You know what he used to do to prep for
that show.
Get picked up by a limo,
get handed the paper,
read it on the way to the studio and
fucking go on there.
That's all he dId.
Just off the top of his head when he was
so relaxed.
Comfortable.
Yeah.
When do I stop doing it?
Maybe that,
the grind to doing it every week.
He did it for a lot of years,
so.
But he still has a show.
He has a show.
Yeah.
He still is some show that I saw and it
was weird.
It was unlike access tv or something
like one of the smaller networks.
yeah.
So I guess he's probably just doing that
for fun,
you know,
just to stay active or something like
that.
Like regis philbin show.
He's,
I'm sure he's got something.
Yeah.
I don't know what it is,
but he,
um,
I think he decided I don't want to do it
anymore.
Yeah.
I mean I guess it's like a jay leno when
he walked away.
Yeah.
But jay's doing that car show now.
That's what I mean in any wanted to do a
little something to stay busy.
Well you did the car show while he was
doing the tonight show.
DAddy.
Yeah.
But the car show is so much more him.
He's so much better on.
Yeah.
He's so busy.
Well he's,
he's a fucking legitimate car
aficionados and nut.
He's a nut.
He fucking loves cars.
So when you're with him and you,
you talking to him about cars,
like he,
his eyes light up,
he gets excited and it's fun.
I did a show that.
Yeah,
we,
uh,
drove my 65 corvette.
Yeah.
And he's,
you know,
he's great.
He's great.
I mean if the public knew him as only
that and you know,
and he,
he'll admitted.
He's like,
that was part of the problem with doing
that show is like I had to talk to
people but I don't give a fuck about
your sitcom or yeah,
you're fucking stupid album that comes
out.
Like he didn't care.
But if he's got you on his car show,
it's because he's legitimately
interested in your car.
That's it.
That's the only reason why he does it.
He's got all the money in the world.
It doesn't give a fuck.
He's only doing it for his own
enjoyment.
Yeah.
I can remember seeing letterman with
like a country music star on.
And you knew that.
He just wanted to say what the fuck?
Yeah.
Yeah,
especially like pop country.
Yeah.
Some wack dude with some designer
fucking cowboy hat on and boots and he's
never worn before and they're all shiny
and fake and his face doesn't change.
Fake samson is right when you see
a country guy with the fake rips in his
jeans.
Oh,
how dare you.
You're not a working man.
How'd you get those ribs bottom?
Yeah.
BoughT those ribS.
You fucked her assistant.
Go out and get riPped or we are,
you get the uh,
the hipsters,
they go out and they buy work boots used
that already are like,
have somebody working in them.
Yeah.
You gotta wear your own work boots.
Fuck man.
Fuck yeah.
Live your life.
I got a pair of timberlands.
I got about 15,
20 years ago.
Really?
Yeah.
They feel nice.
Timberlands and greatest.
They last so good.
There were big in the hip hop community.
Oh yeah.
How'd that happen?
I don't know,
but I know that,
um,
when,
when
don,
was it Dom perignon what one of the
brands that get kind of co opted by?
Hip hop was a crystal.
Yeah,
it was crystal and they were very upset
that hip hop had taken over because here
they are like this elite,
you know,
blue collar,
white collar,
kind of a.
Yeah,
but they started complaining about it
and then the hip hop community rejected.
That's right.
Your fucking sales plummeted.
That's interesting.
You've got to take that money Where you
get it,
but you have a great champagne.
What do you give a fuck?
If rapper start buying rolls royces,
you're goIng to be upset.
Yeah.
No,
come on bitch.
Even if they're spilling your champion
on the floor,
it sounds like racism to me,
as long as it's not spilling it with a
white person,
let them spill it with themselves.
Is weird.
How certain drinks get associated with
certain races.
Like crevasse ea is a black drank,
right?
All right.
I'll name a drink.
You tell me the race.
I'm fucked.
Ripple.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's bark,
right?
Yeah.
The wine manischewitz they know.
I know that is outdated.
I am at sanford because redd foxx used
to rip away.
That's the only way.
I don't even know what it looks like.
I've never seen it.
He has no.
Alright.
Um,
manischewitz oh,
juice,
right.
Um,
bailey's irish cream,
irish breathable,
and it was an easy one.
I'm budweiser,
a white people with marital problems.
Were they caused by the budweiser or
just placated by the budweiser?
All of the above.
It's in the mix.
Champagne
who paUsed?
Shampoo other than like new year's eve.
New year's eve is kind of universal,
right?
Everybody gets champagne and celebrating
shit.
Like weddings who fucked by champagne on
a normal basis.
French people.
Really?
French people drank it.
That makes sense.
Well,
this tasty.
Yeah.
But what about americans?
White assholes.
But they drank.
No,
if you're white asshole,
you drink champagne.
Yeah.
I was thinking of one person
say,
okay,
say it later.
I'll say it later,
although,
you know,
when I used to work as a banquet waiter
at the marriott in boston,
we used to do these banquets and
sometimes they'd come in and they'd,
they'd order.
I'm a dom perignon and I'll tell you
what,
man you get.
It's the best high.
If bad champagne gives you a headache.
It's nasty.
It's sugary,
which is usually sparkling wine.
It's not champagne actual to call it
champagne.
It has to be from this certain region of
France.
The only place you can get it to put
champagne on the label.
Oh,
that's right.
And dom perignon is the best and I'm
telling you,
man,
that shit,
it makes you feel so good.
It tastes so good.
No hangover,
hangover,
no hang.
Well,
not,
not.
Not like champagne hangover,
which is the worst hangover you can get.
Is there really a difference in
hangovers?
Oh yeah.
What's the difference?
Sugar,
sugar,
content,
sugar content.
Hangovers are all about sugar.
Fucking sugar,
right?
As I explained to me by Carl Hart,
Dr.
Carl Hart,
who was an addiction specialist,
he said,
what hangovers really are is your body
got temporarily addicted to the alcohol.
The feeling that you have,
the headache and all that,
a lot of is dehydration,
but a lot of is also the compensatory
mechanisms that your body puts in place
to process the alcohol.
Your body literally shifts.
It's sort of scheduling shifts.
It's a organizing of of chemicals and
all the shit that's in your brain and
then once the alcohol is not there
anymore,
it's not processing alcohol anymore and
then you have this like and that's the
compensatory mechanisms flooding their
way through your system.
That's also why people say,
here are the dog.
That bit you like when you have a
hangover and you have like a bloody mary
in the morning.
It helps you a little bit,
soothes you over that hump because it's
poisonous.
Alcohol is poison.
It's your system.
Yes,
yes.
It's so.
It's counterintuitive that like more
alcohol would help you feel better,
but the way Carl Hart explains it is
that it's your body.
Your body recognizes,
okay,
there's this shit I have to process and
let's deal with that so it compensates
for that shit and then that shit's not
there anymore and it's like,
what's going on?
Where's all the,
what are we doing?
We set up to deal with alcohol.
You know,
we don't have to deal with it anymore.
I had him on a couple of times and he's
a fascinating,
fascinating guy,
very,
very smart guy.
And knows so much about it,
about addictions and about,
um,
about,
uh,
various drugs and the reactions to the
body and all the myths that people have.
It's amazing how many myths that people
have about like how hard things are to
kick and when,
what is instantly addictive.
Yeah.
So that's.
What did he say?
Because I hear cigarettes are the most
addictive cigarettes.
Um,
yes,
it's cigarettes are more addictive than
heroin.
Cigarettes are super,
super addictive.
Yeah.
Super directive.
Well,
they've done.
Did you ever see that movie with russel
crowe inside?
Man?
Yes.
The,
we're about the cigarette industry,
about a.
I'm a scientist that's working with the
cigarettes to try to make them more
addictive and that goes out with it,
which is apparently a real story.
But then they were sued and they lost
it.
They know that's what it doesn't mean
they've engineered them and the
addictive.
Right.
But um,
pot though is not,
they say not physically addictive at
all.
No,
not physically,
but it can be emotionally addictive.
Anything
can,
you know,
like a girl could be emotionally
addictive.
Should we outlaw girls,
you know,
like a Jerking off.
Can be a mo emotionally and
psychologically addictive.
A lot of things can be.
Psychologic foods,
can be psychologically and physically
addictive work,
but one thing that they say about pot is
in rare individuals it can be physically
addictive,
but how Much so is it is physically
addictive as sugar because sugar is one
of the most addictive things that we
consume.
Yeah,
no.
I took a just a few days off of sugaR
and I had fucking pounding headaches.
Yeah.
I was like,
whoa.
Yeah,
I don't.
I'm completely sUgar free now.
I don't eat anything with added sugar.
I don't eat it.
No processed sugar,
no nothing on this wacKy diet that I'm
on,
but I'm.
One of the things that I found within
the first few days was this overwhelming
desire to eat it and liKe I wanted
candy.
I wanted soda.
I wanted something like within the first
couple of dayS,
like my body was.
I get headaches and I would think about
like at see a bag of those,
a chili mangoes that I have back there
that are covered in sugar,
like insane amounts of sugar and I just
want them and it's,
it's a sugar craving.
We did you eat a ton of sugar before you
quit.
Not a ton,
but more than I should've.
And it was all in the guise of healthy
things.
Like,
uh,
for instance,
I was working out with my trainer today
and uh,
he had,
uh,
one of those protein bars and uh,
he goes,
uh,
I said,
hey,
you forgot your candy bar.
He goes,
it's a protein bar.
I go,
hoW much is in that thing?
He goes,
not that much.
I go,
how much do you think?
He goes,
nine grams.
I go,
I go to bed.
I bet it's about 19 grams.
Like,
no,
no.
And he looked at it.
He goes,
10 grams,
and I go,
really?
I go,
how many servings?
And he goes,
oh yeah,
those motherfuckers,
dude,
it was this big.
It was like it wasn't a chocolate.
He won,
it was chocolate.
Chocolate was,
yeah,
it was four inches.
This tiny little thing and they were,
they were calling it to surveil curse
fuckers.
Ten grams of sugar and then you look up
and it's to serve as the cons.
He had my kids eat granola,
my wife buys granola bars for the kids
and it's got chocolate and I'm like,
of these are,
these are candy bars.
Granola bar is like,
you know,
nature valley.
Oh,
you know,
it's got a lot of sugar in it,
but there's no fucking chocolate at
least.
RIght.
But even those,
if you look at the sugar content,
like 10,
11 grams for you always supposed to have
25 grams of sugar in a fucking day.
Yeah.
It's stunning
how much sugar's in everything.
There's a great documentary called that
sugar movie and it just details how all
this happened and how many things have
sugar in them and added sugar and how
bad it is for your body.
It's fucking unbelievable.
It's talk
and How much worse corn syrup is than
shudder.
Yup.
I just did a,
uh,
a corporate event in fargo,
North Dakota for the beet sugar farmers
of America and it was all these farmers
mostly like family owned little farms
around Minnesota and North Dakota and
they came in and I just,
I walked down and walked on stage and I
go,
fuck corn syrup and the placement.
Yeah,
corn syrup just goes right to your house
and it's all because they were over
farming.
Corn is cheap to make and it's easY and
the government was helping pay for it.
And I went,
well,
we're not going to stop.
What do we do with it?
Well,
we'll make fucking sugar.
Adam see king corn now.
Great documentary.
Oh yeah.
Amazing.
It starts off with these guys.
I was a project.
You're going to grow corn.
They're going to like get an acre of
land and plowed themselves and grow corn
and they start doing all these tests and
find out that their Body is like some
insane amount of the carbon fibers in
their body come from corn.
And they're like,
what the fuck?
so they get,
you know,
they get their blood work done,
all this stuff,
they find this out and then they start
going and examining all the different
food it's in the grocery store and how
much of It contains corn,
corn proteins,
corn syrup,
corn byproducts,
and then they go deep,
deep down into the rabbit hole of the
subsidized corn industry and how,
how it all happened,
how it all get started and you leave at
the end of that movie.
Like whAt in the fuck.
We've been cooptive in so many different
ways in this country by special interest
Groups and by people that have figured
out how to generate an extract.
Massive amounts of money from particular
sectors that are not good for us is part
of agriculture.
Corn and ethanol.
Yeah.
Try to figure out how to put in your gas
tank.
Exactly.
Let's dO that.
You have fox not good for your engine,
ethan.
Not good,
not good for your end,
but alcohol is like if they could figure
out how to do alcohol engines,
like the rockefeller thing,
what's wrong with ethanol?
Was it duty engine?
I heard it causes some kind of backup
over times.
Jack bullshit that the oil industry,
so you never knoW.
Do you know john?
John d rockefeller grant,
great,
great grandson now is a heavily into
developing three d,
three d printer meat steaks that come
out of a three d printer and we'll be
using all like soy type ingredients.
They'd be all like,
you know in the printer,
doesn't rot like dry ingredients and you
will be able to.
They can do it now.
They can.
They can make steak chips through a
three d printer.
They're edible And I say it's just a
matter of time until they can make
actual stakes to jesus.
I to how good that is for you.
Well,
it'd be probably better than some kinds
of meats,
but
what they say it's good for third world
countries because there'll be able to.
First Of all,
you won't have to have all that methane
from all the downsides of having cattle.
It can get rid of that.
And then also you can set these things
up in third world country and feed
people.
Fucking poor people.
Imagine them for steak.
What you get them to do
out iphones,
like a motherfucker hungry order steak
from the lab,
rockefeller air invest in from taking.
Scroll down This picture of a state
coming out of a printer.
It's hilarious.
I know there's not a wrong article.
These guys,
do they just,
the rockefeller ehrs,
do they just get cash?
How does that work?
Do they just get money and they just
start their own startup?
What is it?
What do you think that feels like if you
grow up like stupid rich?
We never have to worry about the future
and you're like,
ah,
maybe I'll make a startup.
That's what it should be.
That's the correct use of that money.
I mean,
if you're gonna,
if you're going to get rid of the death
tax or call it really what it is,
these state tax,
at least these people like,
you know,
the kennedys or are doing stuff in the
rockefellers.
You're doing sTuff where they're,
you know,
they're saying,
all right,
without economic pressure,
let me explore and do something a little
on the,
on the fringes that might work.
And you know,
whether it's,
uh,
you know,
non fossil energy or whatever.
And uh,
So it's,
it's pretty cool.
Yeah,
it's nice if you see someone who's given
this unusual roll the dice,
some wonderful hand of cards,
nice.
They use it in a totally egalitarian way
and some,
some beautiful way where they just
decided to donate it or figure out a way
to help or put money into something
that's going to benefit people.
Start a foundation that's just,
you know,
trying to create peace,
which sounds so erudite and
unattainable,
but to go like,
no,
I'm going to work on peace.
Just the concept of peace.
It's just rare.
Yeah.
It's rare that someone just looks at it
and says,
well,
hey,
I have this opportunity to do somethinG
really beneficial for the human race.
Let's take this $100,000,000
that I was born with and put it to use
lIquid robert kennedy's down for the
environment.
I mean,
he,
he's responsible for getting all the
pcbs out of the hudson river and,
uh,
working on making safer a nuclear power.
WhAt do they do to get pcbs out of the
river?
What I mean,
how the fuck do they clean the room
dredge.
They get to go in there and fucking zen
it out.
Some people argue as bad because it
stirs it up.
It will put is in,
you know,
in layers embedded in the,
in the bed of the river.
But they say,
well if a,
if a hurricane or tornado or whatever
comes,
it's gonna.
It's going to bring it up in a much more
destructive way so it's better to bring
it up.
So they bring it up from.
What are they doing when they bring it
up there?
They're cleaning it.
So I guess they,
they filter it,
dump it somewhere.
Huh?
But then he Also just a close up,
there was a,
there was the gm plant,
there was a bunch of plants on the
hudson river that we're dumping raw
sewage in and he stopped.
All of those
are crazy now.
That's wherever you can swim in it.
Watts.
I grew up on the huDson river.
We swim in it and we were told not to.
We were fine,
but now they say,
but now they have like little beaches
setup on the hudson rIver.
Upstate's.
Yeah.
Even in the city,
you can take a fucking kayak out on the
west side and you can swim in it,
swim in it.
That sounds weird.
It gets in your mouth.
Then you die.
Get acute.
Your math class.
Stupid.
No,
they used to bars used to pull lobsters
out of the river.
They used to be bar food.
Yeah.
It was like.
It was thought to be a poor man's meal.
Well,
in Ireland it was.
Yeah,
but even in America he and in the early
days of New York city,
they used to just set out lobster traps
and when someone will order a lobster,
they would just go pull a trap out and
grab one of the lobsters and cook it.
Now she was thought to be a poor food.
Poor people during the famine in
Ireland.
They were exporting lobster was.
They would need it.
They thought it was like a rat.
Oh my god.
Fucking stupid.
Irish.
Stupid.
He fucking data's sitting lobster,
but we don't have any black.
We don't have any butter anyway.
Maybe that's what it is.
I didn't know about butter.
Yeah.
Once you know about butter and lobster,
if someone puts a hold on before you
ship those out,
just try this.
Yeah.
You fucking idiots with this bib on.
You've got to have to bid.
I saw on instagram this guy cooked a
coyote.
He cooked a coyote and barbecued it
barbecue and had barbecue sauce and
brought it to work.
Pulled coyote and apparently so it was
delicious and people were loving it.
Yeah.
There's a lot of shit you can eat.
I mean,
I wouldn't think to eat a coyote.
I saw an episode of mediator,
steve rinella and remy warrant and they
shot a coyote and cooked it over an open
fire and ate it.
Yeah.
Because they want to see what it tasted
like.
There's some good shit if you go to this
restaurant called typhoon and santa
monica and they've got a,
you can eat scorpions and uh,
all shit that would die in a typhoon
right.
Should they might find on the side of
the beach if you want to play out the
post apocalypse,
come to typhoon tuesday night.
Special jelly fish.
Wow.
Scorpions,
scorpions.
Did you try it?
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
Just crunchy,
you know,
a little salty.
Nice.
Well,
they must have added salt,
right?
It's all good protein.
Yeah.
Well they say that bug protein is really
good for you and in a lot of ways I
think that that's gonna be the future of
protein for the world.
Like they have bugged bars and are made
out of like grasshoppers and things
along those lines and um,
it's very healthy,
full amino acid profile and a lot of
people who are maybe vegetarian or vegan
and have a real problem with eating
animals do not have a problem with
eating insects.
They're like,
well,
wait a bug.
Yeah.
I have a friend who's vegan.
He'll fucking slap the shit out of
mosquito on them and kill it and drop it
onto the ground.
Look at the sIngapore style scorpions.
Is that the,
uh,
the menu at that place?
Many taiwanese crickets stir fried raw
garlic,
chili,
pepper and asian bazell.
11 bucks.
Oh,
iT's great.
It's great.
We should eat there.
And one night with the wife.
I'm down.
Let's do it.
Are actually my wife fucking Slap me if
I asked her to eat a bug.
Well they got normal shitty.
They also have pretty good sushi bar,
but yeah,
I'll eat.
I'll eat anything.
I mean I've been down in Florida.
I've eaten alligator.
Alligator is really good for alligators.
Good.
Yeah,
mean apparently an alligator.
It's supposed to be insanely high in
protein and very,
very low in cholesterol.
Yeah.
It's one of the lower thing.
It's like right up there with elk and
moose are apparently the lowest in
cholesterol and lower than chicken.
Yeah.
Tough to cook them though because
there's so little fat.
So you gotta really nail it now.
Yeah.
You just got to learn.
it's just different.
It's different than I got some in the
back.
You want some.
I want some help.
Yeah.
Take it home.
All right.
It's better.
Way better for you.
Higher in protein and there's zero
bullshit in it.
Yeah.
No antibiotics,
no hormones,
no nothing.
Wild game.
And like I said,
lower cholesterol than a chicken breast.
I was in South Africa and we ate at a
game farm,
a game park,
you know,
that they have to thin out the herd,
different animals.
And so they,
there's a restaurant called carnivore,
write it right in the park and they come
around with skewers and they ask you,
do you want some,
uh,
you know,
a giraffe and sharon will give you a
couple of cubes.
Giraffe.
It was like when you took me to that
brazilian restaurant in vegas to haas
Korea.
Yeah.
And they were,
they came over with the skewers and
they,
it was like that,
but it was like elephant fucking,
you know,
different,
different kinds of gazelles and shit.
TheY all had to do retail.
I did eat elephant.
Good.
IT was great.
It was a little gamey.
It had a little smell to it.
People right now are screaming,
screaming,
you fucking you to kill it.
These are all animals that were done.
They should've saved.
Saved.
Hylo is family will always remember.
What about yogi?
Don't eat the jody yogi bear.
What's yogi eat his fucking child on the
internet.
Jesus bears.
Bears are some people who have a weird
connection with bears.
yeah.
They get a,
they get real upset if you kill a bear
stuffed bears,
you know,
the most vicious animal out there that
teddy bear to bed.
Well,
it's,
it's almost like we're trying to make
them less dangerous.
Yeah.
I can make them cuddLy.
Like polar bears are perhaps the most
vicious mammal on earth.
They are fucking monsters.
This guy,
Kevin Fitzgerald,
he's a veterinarian.
Kevin,
you know kevin and denver and he,
um,
we worked together once in denver and he
said that polar bears,
like when you have them as babies right
out of the womb,
they'll try to bite you.
He goes there like the alien,
the alien chest,
burster.
He goes,
that's what they're like right out of
that.
And I was like,
wow,
that is nuts.
He goes,
if they're hungry,
they will try to fucking eat you.
Yeah.
I'm like,
oh my god.
Damn.
Like people have this idea of them as
being this like fluffy creature.
It's like most people live in cities and
most people will comment on animals or
animal rights activists and an animal
rights advocates.
These people have these ideas about the
beautiful nature that we live around
there.
They don't go out in it and you go out
in it.
You really.
It becomes a different thing and you
realize like,
wow,
there's a strange,
like constant conflict going on in this
world.
There's very little harmony.
In fact,
the harmony exist with beings eating
beans.
That's when the harmony exists.
It's all things.
Eating things and things.
Looking out for things that are about to
eat them.
I mean there's a reason why dear perk up
and they move their ears and their head
side to side because somethIng's common
always.
There's always something common and
that's why they run so fast to try to
get away from something.
Eating them.
They're not chasing anything.
Deer run fast because they don't want to
get eaten,
which is fucked.
I saw a rattlesnake.
He to squirrel.
Oh shit.
Saturday,
last summer,
and so I get the squirrel.
I saw him.
He already had the squirrel,
but I saw him take the squirrel into
inside of him and he sought move a
little bit down his body and then a and
everybody got close to them because they
figured just ate right now.
So he was less.
It was a little more lethargic.
Yeah,
you can do that.
And I crawled off as bad.
I'd never seen a rattlesnake before,
nevermind a fuckIng eating a squirrel.
I was running the hills with my dogs and
I ran over what I thought was a log,
like a stick,
like a large stick.
And as I was in the air over it or
realize it was a rattlesnake the size of
my forearm,
no shit.
I was like,
oh fuck.
And I had to keep my dogs back.
Once I realized that it was a
rattlesnake because my dogs have been
bitten several times,
die.
Rattlesnakes.
Uh,
my doc frank,
he got bitten twice and my dog,
lucy,
she got bitten once and their face
swells up and it's,
it's bad,
it's bad.
But they'll go and attack the rattle
snake even though they know they'll get
bit.
Well,
they'll bark and they get near it and
they bark,
bark,
and then the snakes bite them in the
face.
Yeah.
Wow.
They don't know what it is.
They just know it's dangerous.
like something in their doggy brain is
like,
this ain't cool.
Like what the fuck is this thing?
And they bark at it.
Whereas they don't bark at squirrels.
If they see a squirrel that chase after
it and try to kill it.
Yeah.
But if they see a rattlesnake,
they uh,
they get close and I don't know,
I wasn't there when it actually went
down.
I was there in the aftermath.
I saw the snake,
I pulled him away.
I looked at him,
I looked at his face and I'm like,
what's going on?
I saw a little holes.
I'm like,
goddammit.
He got bit.
So I had to take him in.
And one time I took him to the guide.
If you hadn't taken them in,
uh,
probably.
Probably eventually.
Yeah,
it takes awhile.
But they swell up like crazy.
Like the side of their face becomes a
cartoonish where they got stung.
Especially a young rattlesnake.
Young rattlesnakes are the most
dangerous because they don't know any
better.
They empty out all their venom in one
shot.
The old rattlesnakes just give you a
little taste.
It's like take that motherfucker,
but they keep some for the kids.
Have that bite you again or buy
something else an hour later.
Um,
but one time frank got bit and I looked
at,
um,
and um,
I,
um,
I killed a rattlesnake and then I looked
at him.
I go kill it.
Uh,
I think I used to rake forget what to
killed it with.
I just killed it.
Um,
but um,
then I looked at frank and people are
like,
why would you do that?
Because it's in my yard.
Sorry.
See that fence you get inside that
you're dead.
If you can kill me,
You fucked up.
I kill you in my house.
I'll kill you in my yard,
my yard.
And you're dead.
You're dead.
CoyoTes dead.
If I'm practicing archery in my yard and
I see a coyote,
yes,
I'm shooting that thing.
Joe rogan was killed up,
sat in my apartment for me.
That's right.
I did with a tennis racket.
Without even thinking about it.
Then sat down and watched tv.
Five seconds later I ran after that
thing.
Yeah.
It's disturbing to switch.
Then what happened with frank?
Oh.
Anyway,
so I brought him to the vet and the vet
looks at him and this is like,
uh,
after like the first time frank and lucy
both got bit and then this is like a
maybe a year later,
um,
I wasn't sure if he got bit because I
saw the rattlesnake and I saw him.
I killed a rattlesnake and then I'm
like,
come here buddy,
let me check your face out.
And I'm looking at him and I don't see
any marks.
And I'm like,
wow,
you seem all right,
but fuck,
I don't know.
Come on,
let's go.
And I'd take him in the back of the
truck and I drag 'em,
take them down to the vet and the vet
checks them out and he goes,
oh,
I don't see any swelling.
Everything seems fine.
I'm like,
all right.
And then I'd take them back home.
This face started swelling,
delayed reaction.
I think maybe he got like a small dose,
like it wasn't a lot,
but within an hour he was like,
it's hard to tell because it's
adrenaline is so fired up,
you know?
His tongue was as a and he was like so
excited to get to get in the car and go
drive around.
Yeah.
He seemed normal,
but then an hour or so later after I got
him home,
his face started swelling so I had to
bring them back in.
You got to give him the antivenom.
It's fucking expensive.
It's thousands of dollars.
So if you're shit,
it's no joke.
So if you're broke and your dog gets
bit,
it's a fucker man.
You suck it out yourself.
That's a myth too.
The only Way you could suck it out as if
you get it right when it's happened.
like right.
like if it bites you right there,
you'd make a tourniquet.
You goT to cut yourself too.
You gotta.
You can't be shy about it.
You got to cut into with that area,
with that fucking snake is squeeze it
and suck it out and you're probably not
going to get it all.
You're going to get some of it,
but if you ever seen what happens to a
person when they get bit by a
rattlesnake,
oh my god,
we are so weak.
Where such we're water bags when we just
a little bags of water.
We're just so we're.
We're allergic to everything.
He this guy put a website up that
documents him getting bit
by a rattlesnake like after he got bit
hit him seeking treatment than the neck
grow.
Necropsy,
what would you call it?
What is it called?
Necrosis.
When skins dying and the tissues dying
all around the wound and he had to get a
skin transplants and all this crazy shit
and it took a long time and he
documented the entire procedure.
This is one guy like,
oh wow.
No shit.
Ton.
Texas country star,
Kevin Fowler per pulse.
gnarly rattlesnake picture.
This guy has his hand.
Looks like.
I mean,
it looks like he has a globe in his
hand,
like his hand is swollen and black so
far,
so far.
Swollen forearm a little further.
I think that's the one.
Go to that website visit page.
Um,
this is,
this is the verY,
this is the very website where it
documents this guy that's,
that's actually one photo that's taken
from the website,
but there's a website where it shows
this is the absolute one guy got bitten
and his skin all dyed.
HIs skin died.
And uh,
I believe it was a young kid too.
I don't think he was very young,
very old when this happened and just put
mesh over it.
Well that mesh is so that his skin a
grows in place and then they take the
graft and they try to put it over that.
But it is,
it's rough,
man.
It's,
um,
it's very,
very fucking dangerous.
You gotta write rattlesnake.
You can't just write,
but anyway,
I'm not.
No bueno.
I was up on that same trip to South
Africa.
My,
my daughter was probably about three and
then we went down to the uh,
in,
in cape town.
There's the cape of good hope is that
the little thing that sticks out there
haven't been,
and you can hike through this field and
get to the,
it is like the southwestern tip of
europe and africa and so we go down
there and we get out of the car and
there's all these baboons and they're
fucking vicious and they're aggressive
and the park ranger was like,
um,
yeah,
you may want to keep her in your arms
the whole time.
AnD I was like,
why?
And they're like,
well,
if the snakes don't get it,
bad wounds,
just going to grab her.
I just watching your daughter get taken
by a fucking bad balloon and eaton or
taken by a fucking giant bella chimps.
Chimps take babies.
Yeah.
Fuck.
That would be close to up there with
your worst nightmare.
top three worst nightmares,
pat boone and taking your child is as
they scream.
Yeah.
Baboons might aLso might even be worse
than a lion.
Yeah,
both would be horrific.
But there's something about a primate
doing it.
Yeah.
That's baboons are so weird.
It's like a monkey.
That dog,
you know,
some weird sort of half,
half monkey,
half dog face thing.
she's so aggressive,
so aggressive and their hands are just a
long arms and strong hands come right at
you.
Creepy fox.
Yeah.
shit,
I've never seen a documentary they did
with um,
they,
they teamed dogs like baboons,
actually tame dogs and they taught these
dogs had to be like,
watch dogs get.
Yeah,
they,
they took these dogs in and fed them.
Like in they had these tribes of baboons
and they had figured out that this up as
an experiment or just had another dog.
The baboons did it.
The baboons have these dogs and fed them
and then the dogs like stayed around
them.
And when anything would come near,
the dogs would bark and the baboons
would come out and no shit.
Yeah,
they're smart as fuck dude.
Damn.
They're creepy and their world is harsh
and you know,
so their actions don't seem like
intelligent actions,
you know,
they don't have community and it's,
it's not like a,
they have an a language and you rapid
use of tools or anything like that.
But they're very intelligent and some
sort of a weird way.
They figure if they figure out problems
and then we stick them in steel cages
for life.
There was an article that a tweeted
today,
see if he could see that they believe
that chimpanzees and monkeys have just
started using stone tools over the last
40,000
years and that chimps are entering the
age,
the stone age.
Like there they are evolving.
Chimps and monkeys have entered the
stone age in the wild.
Yes.
In the wild.
They're actually evolving and that this
could eventually lead to chimps becoming
something very different than what they
are now.
That what we're seeing now,
you know,
a million years from now,
chimps might not be chimps anymore.
They could become neanderthals.
It can become us.
We've only been us for a couple of
hundred thousand years.
Yeah.
You know,
he,
um,
I'm listening to this book right now on
tape about,
uh,
you know,
or like prehistoric man from like the
first socialization.
Oh,
uh,
what's it called?
Sapiens.
Who wrote that?
Um,
we're at sapiens
do Your,
do you will yuval noah harari?
Well,
what a name you've brief history of
humankind and just talking,
talking.
Yeah.
It's talkiNg about how,
you know,
neanderthal man and um,
um,
what was the one that,
and,
and he and homo sapiens,
which is what came after neanderthal
people think there was like a timeline
because when you look at timelines,
it lists one,
then there's a line segment and then the
next one starts.
But there was a time when they were both
on the earth at the same time and they
were fighting and neanderthal was
fucking way bigger.
a more powerful way.
Stronger and bigger brains and big.
Right.
Which is weird.
Yeah.
They don't even know why.
They don't know if the brain was bigger
to control the body because they don't
have one to study all the speculation of
how smart they were.
Yeah.
And it was a battle in the,
uh,
the sapiens one because they had
techniques for hunter working as a group
and surrounding the other ones.
And they use tools.
Uh,
I guess,
I don't know if it was rocks or whatever
it is that they use,
that the neanderthals were not using.
I think it's they just divided them and
fuck them all.
Yeah.
And became,
They became us.
How did they don't know?
That's my fear.
My,
they were on top.
I don't wonder man.
I mean they know that there was some
interbreeding yeah.
or at least they believed or some
interbreeding and they recently found
some,
a bone of an ancient neanderthal that
had human dna in it.
And so they're like,
well,
what the fuck?
Yeah.
See if you find that,
because I think I tweeted that recently
too,
but just might,
I might not be human.
You mean sapient?
Yes.
Homeless in dma.
I mean because I guess neanderthal or
human type of humans.
Is that what they are?
Uh,
yeah.
I guess there's homo erectus,
homo,
whatever.
And then homosapien is what's considered
modern man.
Yeah.
they don't necessarily hear it is humans
made with neanderthals much earlier and
more frequently than thought.
This is really recently.
This is February 17th?
Yeah.
people will fuck a sheep will fuck
anything.
I can't believe I never fucked an
animal.
You know?
I was so horny when I was a teenager,
I think because we didn't have pets.
It's the only thing that stopped dog.
Fuck that.
I would've fucked my dog.
Definitely.
What?
Depending on the kind of.
Well also we grew up without rampant
access to pornography like these kids
have today.
Yeah.
Like if a kid today as an iphone,
you've got all the porn in the world at
your fingertips,
bam.
You could watch people.
Fuck.
All I had was a sheep dog.
Vaseline.
It's hard back then.
Yeah,
I can.
Uh,
and,
and you know,
the final nude episode,
new tradition of playboys coming out.
Pam anderson will be the last nude model
in playboy history.
Great.
Someone no one Wants to see negative
anymore.
Perfect cutaway to go out,
go out with a fizzle.
Ease us out.
Even if she doesn't look good.
What are you looking at is not really
that person anymore.
And looking at photoshop elements,
you know,
you're lookIng at well hurt,
you mean physically that she's not her
own parts and then they'll photoshop.
But on top of that,
yeah,
you're not looking at the real image and
you're looking at some distorted like
they have you ever seen what they do?
Like they've shown like the real image
versus what they do.
Here she is right there.
She was a beauty in her day time is a
motherfucker off of youtube that please
do that sex tape and her prime.
Amazing.
She was so hot.
Wait,
these aren't the most recent ones?
Allegedly.
Oh really?
This was from december?
Yeah.
See it's all what?
Weird.
Black and white.
But you know the old hiding behind her
pulling skin right there.
She got midgets.
Fucking high powered fans.
Blowing her sag up.
She's right next to the star of heft.
I don't know man.
It's like.
Yeah,
she was smart.
She would made herself look at least a
little bit old in these instead of.
She looks 19.
Well it's like everything's blurry in
hazy.
It's like you're looking at it through
the fog.
Like a spotlight in a foggy room.
Any shots of her feet?
just the shooting age.
Yes they do.
Boy,
do they.
Okay.
Come on.
She doesn't look at the hemorrhoids
coming out of her ass.
That is not what she looks like.
She just doesn't.
I mean,
that's not accurate.
So stupid.
She said,
yeah.
She said kids,
but she's also 50,
you know,
I mean she's not a cindy crawford.
50 either.
Cindy crawford looks great next to her.
Recently.
You were bowling.
We did this thing.
We help out with these.
I'm a retarded kids.
You think you're supposed to say that?
Mentally.
Whatever.
Intellectually disabled children.
It's this group that me and my son
worked with and they do a bowling thing
to raise money for them and you bowl
with the mentally challenged kids and
she's really active with it and share it
out there with her kids.
Her daughter is a model now are sons a
model?
And she looked fucking crate,
which is like 51.
She looked thIrty.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Once you hit a good 30 to not like some
thirties,
you know?
I knew a girl when she was 19 and then I
saw her again when she was 27 and
apparently she had a meth problem.
Oh.
And when I saw her when she was 27,
she looked like she had been to hell and
back and she looked easily 50 and she
wasn't even 30 yet and I was like,
wow,
like meth,
something about stimulants,
man.
You that red lining the system,
but what you pay for that you pay for
that,
what drives you out?
She looked terrible.
Yeah.
Terrifying to her skin was hanging off
of her bones or muscle tissue.
It all gone away.
She,
it'd all atrophied.
So like,
or like what?
The plumpness of youth.
It all been replaced by like this dead
air and her skin was looking for all the
meat that used to be there to hold it in
place.
It was just sagging and oh my.
And you know,
she chained,
smoked the whole time.
She was definitely chainsmoking.
She's,
she was a smoker,
but it was sad and she was so apologetic
about,
oh,
she was apologetic about the way she
looked.
It was really disturbing.
Yeah.
I just saw this girl that I hadn't seen
in awhile and she gave me a hug and she
goes,
I'm sorry,
I got really fat,
like you're apologizing to me.
Like that is so weird.
It might be the same person did the same
thing to me.
We'll talk about it off air now.
I don't think so.
This girl is never on trucks.
You just put on a different girl.
Just did that recently to me.
Okay.
Comedy store.
Yeah.
We'll talk.
We'll talk about this is we've got to
end this thing anyway.
I got to get the fuck out of here to
marlboro.
Greg fitzsimmons and I will be
performing at the improv in
motherfucking hollywood.
are you still doing your show on sirius
or is it only a podcast now?
Still do the show monday nights on
serious.
It's the greg fitzsimmons shell on
howard,
one one.
then the podcast is fits dog radio.
I just had a arch fear just came on.
Duncan trussell just came on a judd
apatow.
Just came on those.
Those will all be up in the next week or
so.
Excellent.
And then denver,
Colorado.
Can I plug that comedY works comedy
works in denver,
coming up on the 24th through the 26th
and then I am in a.
Sorry,
one of my all time favorite clubs ever.
Sacramento punchline.
April.
Neither one of my all time favorite
clubs.
San francisco punch line 21 through 23.
And then other dates,
comics and Connecticut.
All@fitsdog.com.
They're comics have construct can suck
my dick,
but the other clubs are great.
Alright ladies and gentlemen,
that's it for today.
See you soon.
You fucks.